Happy New Year, everyone.
大家新年快乐。
Josh and Craig here.
乔什和克雷格在这里。
We are taking this week off to ring in the New Year, but we don't want to leave you without an episode to ring it in with.
我们将在本周休假以迎接新年，但我们不想让您没有一集来迎接新年。
So we are replaying, repeating, re...
所以我们不断地重播、重复、再...
We just, it's a rerun, let's just call it.
我们只是，这是重播，我们就这么称呼吧。
Let's say what it is.
我们来说说它是什么。
We don't want to disrespect you on this.
我们不想在这件事上不尊重你。
We're rerunning a great episode from season one called The Limo.
我们正在重播第一季中名为“豪华轿车”的精彩剧集。
We hope you enjoy it.
我们希望您喜欢它。
We loved revisiting this episode.
我们喜欢重温这一集。
episode.
插曲。
It was hard to shoot.
拍摄起来很困难。
We remember.
我们记得。
But it turned out great.
但结果很棒。
And what else?
还有什么？
What else to say about the limo, Craig?
关于豪华轿车还有什么要说的，克雷格？
It's one of our own.
这是我们自己的之一。
I mean, it's, we didn't do any years of episode every year.
我的意思是，我们每年都没有做任何一集。
I don't think we had one season two, for example.
例如，我认为我们没有第二季。
So it's kind of it's cool.
所以这有点酷。
It's I love this one very much, not Moby.
我非常喜欢这个，而不是莫比。
There are so many things in this episode.
这一集的事情实在是太多了。
It's our only episode.
这是我们唯一的一集。
I think that takes place almost exclusively in a limo, which we thought would be easy to shoot and was a nightmare to shoot.
我认为这几乎完全发生在豪华轿车中，我们认为这很容易拍摄，但拍摄起来却是一场噩梦。
So please enjoy us, remembering what a nightmare it was to shoot and the amazing episode came out of it.
所以请享受我们，记住拍摄过程是一场噩梦，而令人惊叹的一集却由此而来。
Hi guys, my name is Andrea, I'm from Mexico and I really do love the episode about the limo.
大家好，我叫安德里亚，我来自墨西哥，我真的很喜欢关于豪华轿车的剧集。
I've actually watched it every single New Year's Eve right after 12th and honestly the funny thing is New Year's Eve is like my least favorite holiday of all but I don't know this episode just says to me what's important about a holiday you know like it's not about what party you go to or about gifts or about you know make it extraordinary but about the people you actually spend it with about reflecting about being thankful for one another and I don't know I guess that's just one of the things that I love the most about the show that it makes you come back to the people you love and making sure you spend the most time as possible.
事实上，我在12号之后的每个除夕夜都看过它，老实说，有趣的是除夕夜就像是我最不喜欢的节日，但我不知道这一集只是告诉我，你所知道的假期有什么重要的，就像这不是关于你去参加什么聚会，或者关于礼物，或者关于你认识的使它变得非凡，而是关于你真正与之一起度过的人，关于反思彼此的感恩，我不知道，我想这只是其中一件事我最喜欢这个节目，它让你回到你爱的人身边，并确保你花尽可能多的时间。
You can with them and cherish each other.
你可以和他们在一起，互相珍惜。
Thank you so much for doing this podcast.
非常感谢您制作这个播客。
This is amazing.
这太棒了。
So thank you and thank you for changing my life for the better.
所以谢谢你，谢谢你让我的生活变得更好。
I'm alone, won't be soon.
我一个人，不会很快。
You know York City, when I see you.
当我见到你时，你就知道约克市。
Please permit me to tell you everything, York City.
请允许我告诉你一切，约克市。
Well, hello, welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
好吧，你好，欢迎收看《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的另一集。
I'm Josh Radner and I am joined by my friend Craig Thomas.
我是乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner)，我的朋友克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 也加入了我的行列。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
Hi.
你好。
I almost cry every time at the openings now.
现在每次开场我都几乎哭了。
I know.
我知道。
I'm going to produce your aliquets together.
我要一起制作你们的等分。
I literally almost start to cry every time.
我每次都几乎开始哭泣。
Andrea, I kind of thought, it's so beautiful.
安德里亚，我想，它太漂亮了。
We could just play that letter.
我们可以直接播放那封信。
It's like, that's pretty much the episode in some way.
就好像，从某种程度上来说，这就是这一集。
She summed it up.
她总结道。
So thank you for joining us on today's episode.
感谢您加入我们今天的节目。
It was just to be the shortest one.
这只是为了成为最短的一个。
So if you're just tuning in, Andrea from Mexico, which I just love that letter.
如果你刚刚收听，来自墨西哥的安德里亚，我非常喜欢这封信。
Thank you so much for that, Andrea.
非常感谢你，安德里亚。
She was talking about episode 11 of how I met your mother.
她正在谈论我如何遇见你母亲的第11集。
I'm getting confused about titles.
我对标题感到困惑。
Like I say, how I made your mother, made your mother very tricky.
就像我说的，我如何造就了你的母亲，让你的母亲变得非常棘手。
But on this podcast, we are doing a rewatch.
但在这个播客中，我们正在重新观看。
I played Ted Mosby on the show from, what was it, 2005 to 2014?
我在 2005 年到 2014 年的节目中扮演 Ted Mosby？
I was in every single episode.
我参加了每一集。
Craig Thomas probably had a line or two, or every line in many of the episodes.
克雷格·托马斯可能有一两句台词，或者许多剧集中的每一句台词。
He co-created the show.
他共同创作了该节目。
I got in two jokes in the series.
我在这个系列中遇到了两个笑话。
He got in two jokes.
他开了两个玩笑。
I got two jokes.
我有两个笑话。
He co-created the show with Carter Bayes.
他与卡特·贝叶斯共同创作了该节目。
And we're working our way through it, and we're unpacking this mystery of why the show has endured, why people love it so much, why people watch the limo episode every New Year's Eve and what the show just has done to people and continues to do.
我们正在努力解决这个问题，我们正在解开这个谜团：为什么这部剧经久不衰，为什么人们如此喜爱它，为什么人们每年除夕夜都会观看豪华轿车剧集，以及这部剧对人们做了什么，并将继续做什么。
But before we started, we start today, Craig, talking about the limo episode 11.
但在我们开始之前，克雷格，我们今天开始谈论豪华轿车第 11 集。
I did want to do a little State of the Union and I just wanted to ask you, how's it going doing this podcast for you?
我确实想做一些国情咨文，我只是想问你，你做这个播客怎么样？
Oh, I love it.
哦，我喜欢它。
And you've chosen the perfect moment to do State of the Union because this is episode 11 out of 22, almost all of the seasons were either 22 episodes or 24, 24 in success.
你选择了制作《国情咨文》的最佳时机，因为这是 22 集中的第 11 集，几乎所有的剧集要么是 22 集，要么是 24、24 集，都很成功。
Once we became sort of more of a hit, they're like, give us a couple extra a year.
一旦我们变得更受欢迎，他们就会说，一年多给我们几个。
And that was a very good sign when I went out to 24.
当我24岁的时候，这是一个非常好的迹象。
And one year because of the writer's strike in 2007, it was only 20.
而由于2007年作家罢工，这一年只剩下20年。
But so right now we're at the exact midpoint and I am loving it.
但现在我们正处于中间点，我很喜欢它。
I have not watched a lot of these episodes in years, getting to watch it and sort of share it with fans and here like we just did that amazing opening of this episode, here what it means to people, I just find it's so moving.
我已经很多年没有看过很多这样的剧集了，能够观看它并与粉丝分享，就像我们刚刚为这一集做了令人惊叹的开场一样，这对人们意味着什么，我发现它是如此感人。
It's just, I feel like I'm watching it, I feel like a different person watching it.
只是，我觉得我在看它，我感觉就像是另一个人在看它。
I was so close to it when we were making it.
当我们制作它时，我非常接近它。
I saw it through such different eyes and I'm loving it, I'm loving it.
我通过不同的眼睛看到了它，我很喜欢它，我很喜欢它。
It's wonderful and sort of, I'm marveling at what we did 20 years ago, right?
这太棒了，我对 20 年前我们所做的事情感到惊讶，对吧？
I can't sort of can't believe a lot of it.
我有点不敢相信其中很多。
I'm like, how do we do that?
我想，我们该怎么做？
We didn't know what we're doing.
我们不知道自己在做什么。
I think when you're in it and you're close to it and an episode's airing six weeks after you just made it, for me, my ego was just tied up in it in a different way than it is now.
我认为当你身处其中并且你已经接近它并且一集在你刚刚制作后六周播出时，对我来说，我的自我只是以一种与现在不同的方式被束缚在其中。
I watch it with so much more forgiveness and I'm marveling at the fact that I was involved in this charming show that continues to delight people.
我带着更多的宽容来观看它，我很惊讶我参与了这个继续让人们高兴的迷人节目。
And I just told you, I've just gotten back from the one leg of my tour And I'm meeting all of these people who, you know, just the waitress at the restaurant I was at last night said, I got my whole sense of humor from you.
我刚刚告诉过你，我刚刚从我的旅程中回来，我遇到了所有这些人，你知道，只是我昨晚去的餐厅的女服务员说，我的全部幽默感都是从你们那里得到的。
It's your wish you don't.
这是你的愿望，你却不愿意。
That's what you said, that's so cool.
这就是你说的，太酷了。
I said, well, let's see what you got.
我说，好吧，让我们看看你得到了什么。
I'll be the judge of that.
我将对此做出判断。
Yeah, let's do it.
是的，我们就这么做吧。
But, you know, I was thinking sometimes, I think that there's a tendency to dismiss TV.
但是，你知道，我有时在想，我认为人们有一种忽视电视的倾向。
And I've been guilty of this too, as a kind of a popular medium that maybe, well, I think there's been so much quality television in almost novelistic ways.
我也对此感到内疚，作为一种流行媒体，也许，嗯，我认为以近乎小说的方式出现了如此多的高质量电视。
Our show, The Wire, The Sopranos, like TV has really been elevated to high art, but it's also a populist medium, right?
我们的节目《火线》、《黑道家族》，就像电视一样，确实被提升为高雅艺术，但它也是一种民粹主义媒体，对吗？
It's in everyone's home and now pockets, living rooms.
它在每个人的家里，现在在口袋里、客厅里。
But if you think about our human need for story, I'm sure people were stopping Sophocles on the street in the Algora or whatever, and being like, I don't remember what he wrote, but you know what I mean?
但如果你想想我们人类对故事的需求，我确信人们会在阿尔戈拉或其他地方的街上拦住索福克勒斯，然后说，我不记得他写了什么，但你知道我的意思吗？
Like saying like, I think smoking in the banded too is what he wrote.
就像说的那样，我认为他写的也是在带子里吸烟。
Not that I'm saying, you know, stopping a playwright agrees to sing the Orestaya Trilogy really floored me.
我并不是说，你知道，阻止一位剧作家同意演唱《奥瑞斯塔亚三部曲》真的让我感到震惊。
But I've got a few notes.
但我有一些笔记。
Actually an answer for you.
其实给你一个答案。
Can you sign just, yeah, Elektra on my arm, because I'm gonna get a hat to you.
你能在我手臂上签名吗，是的，艾丽卡，因为我要给你戴一顶帽子。
That's what people want me to write people while they answer on their arms, they get a tattoo.
这就是人们希望我写的，而他们在手臂上回答，他们纹身。
But I think there is a human, I really maintain there's these human ache for stories.
但我认为是有人类存在的，我确实认为人类对故事有着渴望。
We need them.
我们需要他们。
And when people say to me like, this show changed my life, it taught me how to talk with my dad, it got me through my divorce, it gave me my sense of humor.
当人们对我说，这个节目改变了我的生活，它教会了我如何与我的父亲交谈，它帮助我度过了离婚，它给了我幽默感。
I take that really seriously now, and I really can't, I continue to be moved to have been a part of something that affected people this way.
我现在非常认真地对待这一点，我真的不能，我继续被感动成为以这种方式影响人们的事情的一部分。
But I also, you know, it's so strange to be watching this with my wife and watching almost every episode with her, except this episode we were separate, because I was on tour, but just to look back, it's weird when you do something on camera for this long.
但我也，你知道，和我的妻子一起看这个节目，几乎每一集都和她一起看，这很奇怪，除了这一集我们是分开的，因为我在巡演，但回顾一下，当你在镜头前做这么长时间的事情时，感觉很奇怪。
It's almost like you have this weird moving in both senses of the word, like photo album of your life.
这几乎就像你在这个词的两种意义上都有这种奇怪的感动，就像你生活的相册一样。
It's like, it's this weird documentary snapshot.
就像，这是一张奇怪的纪录片快照。
And even though that wasn't what was going on in my life, It was partly what was going on in my life.
尽管这不是我生活中正在发生的事情，但这也是我生活中正在发生的事情的一部分。
At least that was my job.
至少那是我的工作。
But most people don't have their jobs filmed and then he's out to the rest of the world.
但大多数人的工作并没有被拍摄下来，然后他就去了世界其他地方。
And it feels so weird.
而且感觉很奇怪。
I think about this from your perspective in this rewatch so often.
在这次重看中，我经常从你的角度思考这个问题。
I'm like, well, Josh knows where he was that day.
我想，好吧，乔什知道他那天在哪里。
That's him popping out of the top of a limo.
那是他从豪华轿车的顶部跳出来。
He's like, that's what I was doing that day of work of my life 20 years ago.
他说，这就是 20 年前我一生中最重要的一天所做的事情。
No one gets that and that's you.
没有人明白这一点，那就是你。
That's you at that age, at that minute, existing on planet Earth in that moment and watching it again and kind of going back into that.
那就是你在那个年龄，在那一刻，在那一刻存在于地球上，再次观看它，然后又回到了那个时刻。
Like, I'm having a little bit of that kind of vertigo of like, I remember I was standing off to the side at Video Village watching the four cameras, you know, the four monitors showing the four camera shots.
就像，我有一点眩晕感，我记得我站在视频村的一边看着四个摄像机，你知道，四个监视器显示四个摄像机的镜头。
But what is it?
但它是什么？
Is there kind of like a weird emotional vertigo of trying to like remember your way back into like what it looked like, say within that limo?
是不是有一种奇怪的情绪眩晕感，试图记住自己回到原来的样子，比如说在豪华轿车里？
That just occurred to me.
我刚刚想到了这一点。
I remember, I think sometimes when you're in the apartment or you're in the bar, we did so much in there that it's hard to isolate.
我记得，有时当你在公寓或酒吧里时，我们在那里做了很多事情，很难被隔离。
Oh, I remember that day, unless something really particularly strange happened.
哦，我记得那天，除非真的发生了特别奇怪的事情。
But the limo became shorthand for this prison that we all shared together.
但豪华轿车成了我们共同居住的这座监狱的代名词。
Like, I remember us saying limo, like, whatever was going on, we'd be like, well, at least we're not in the limo because it was so intense.
就像，我记得我们说豪华轿车，就像，无论发生什么，我们都会说，好吧，至少我们不在豪华轿车里，因为它太激烈了。
And I think, remind me, was it all shot in an actual limo or was some of it tricked out, like, to look like a limo?
我想，提醒我一下，这一切都是在一辆真正的豪华轿车中拍摄的，还是其中一些是经过精心设计的，比如看起来像一辆豪华轿车？
Did we shoot some of it on the stage?
我们在舞台上拍过一些吗？
I can't remember.
我不记得了。
Well, I, it was an episode that Carter was on the set for and he would probably have more memories than me, so I wish we had him on this one.
嗯，我，这是卡特在片场拍摄的一集，他可能比我有更多的回忆，所以我希望我们让他来出演这一集。
But I think, no, I think we had, we were shooting the inside of the limo.
但我想，不，我想我们有，我们正在拍摄豪华轿车的内部。
I think it was, a lot of it was really in that limo, I think, and it was really hard to shoot.
我想是的，很多都是在那辆豪华轿车里，我想，而且真的很难拍摄。
It was cramped.
房间很狭窄。
I mean, a lot of times there were like four people in like a three-person back seat.
我的意思是，很多时候有四个人坐在一个三人后座上。
I did, I do have very strong memories of, one thing I really loved was how the sunroof kind of area becomes this other playing space.
我做到了，我确实有非常强烈的记忆，我真正喜欢的一件事是天窗区域如何成为另一个游戏空间。
It's like another room.
这就像另一个房间。
Well, it's like stepping out onto the balcony, right?
嗯，就像走到阳台上一样，对吧？
Like it has that feel, and I just love, I remember very strongly like when it was joyful to get out of the limo, kind of get some air and pop up, but I really liked all the scenes that were played up there.
就像它有那种感觉，我只是喜欢，我记得非常强烈，就像从豪华轿车里出来，呼吸一些空气并弹出一样，但我真的很喜欢那里播放的所有场景。
I found it really, and I remember that final scene with Kobe, and maybe it was because it was episode 11, but this episode I think does a very good job, and we'll summarize what the episode is in one second, but it does a very good job of being, like we said, a self-contained episode, you could just tune in and you watch this gang of friends try to navigate this crazy New Year's Eve.
我真的找到了，我记得科比的最后一幕，也许是因为那是第11集，但我认为这一集做得非常好，我们会在一秒钟内总结这一集的内容，但它做得很好，就像我们说的，一个独立的剧集，你只需收听，你就可以看到这群朋友试图驾驭这个疯狂的除夕夜。
But also the Ted and Robin thing, it's like you move the ball down the field.
还有泰德和罗宾的事情，就像你把球移到球场上一样。
Like it really does that thing you guys were trying to do.
就像它确实做到了你们想做的事情一样。
You were having your cake and eating it too, I think in a really nice way here.
你一边吃着蛋糕，一边吃着它，我认为这里的方式非常好。
Yeah, the very end of that episode where he walks across the street and the light changes to like walk as he walks into kind of the future.
是的，在那一集的最后，他走过街道，当他走进某种未来时，灯光变成了走路的样子。
I love that shot.
我喜欢那个镜头。
First of all, Pam Fryman.
首先是帕姆·弗莱曼。
When Pam Fryman would do put together a shot like that, we'd call it, we'd say, that shot was deep fried, the pan-fryment.
当帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman）将这样的镜头放在一起时，我们会称其为油炸镜头，即煎锅。
And that is a deep fried shot, that is a classic.
那是油炸镜头，这是经典。
And it feels like he's walking into a new year.
感觉就像他正在步入新的一年。
He's walking into a new chapter.
他正在步入新的篇章。
We don't know what's gonna happen.
我们不知道会发生什么。
It's a great way to say the audience, hey, keep watching.
这是向观众说“嘿，继续看”的好方法。
You're gonna see some cool stuff.
你会看到一些很酷的东西。
And it's also, it's a purely cinematic moment.
而且，这也是一个纯粹的电影时刻。
Like I'm always looking for moments, like I'm going to quote, I'm going to reference my own work, but in liberal arts, it's, there's this somewhat of a romance, but not quite between a 35-year-old and a 19-year-old.
就像我总是在寻找时刻，就像我要引用的那样，我要引用我自己的作品，但在文科领域，有一点浪漫，但不完全是在 35 岁和 19 岁之间。
And he's obsessed with their age difference as he should be.
他对他们的年龄差异很着迷，这是他应该做的。
And he works out the math.
他算了算。
He says, when I was, you know, 16, she was zero.
他说，当我，你知道，16 岁的时候，她是零。
When I was 19, she was three.
那年我19岁，她三岁。
But then he goes, well, when I'm so-and-so she'll be so.
但后来他走了，好吧，当我是某某时，她也会是这样。
And then the age starts seeming like less of a problem.
然后年龄就开始不再是一个问题了。
But it's a totally silent scene.
但这是一个完全安静的场景。
And it goes back and forth.
它来回。
It's just an inner, a close insert shot on the page a page and his face, boom, boom, boom.
这只是一个内部的、近距离的插入镜头，在一页一页上和他的脸，繁荣，繁荣，繁荣。
And the thing I loved about that is you cannot do that in a theater.
我喜欢的一点是你不能在剧院里这样做。
That is a purely like cinematic shot.
这是一个纯粹像电影的镜头。
And I love the last shot of the limo because him walking away with that little grin on his face and the camera pulling up and just catching the go, the pedestrian go sign is that is movie making.
我喜欢豪华轿车的最后一个镜头，因为他走开时脸上带着微笑，镜头拉起，正好捕捉到行人走动的迹象，那就是电影制作。
Like that is like, it tells you everything you need to know and you feel it in your chest.
就像那样，它会告诉你你需要知道的一切，并且你会在胸中感受到它。
It doesn't, uh, it's not words.
这不是，呃，这不是言语。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
今天我写信给你，是为了送你去纽约。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
And also, I should say, I found this, I looked up some fun facts about this episode.
而且，我应该说，我发现了这一点，我查找了有关这一集的一些有趣的事实。
Our cinematographer, Chris LaFontaine, won an Emmy for cinematography for this episode.
我们的电影摄影师克里斯·拉方丹 (Chris LaFontaine) 凭借本集获得了艾美奖摄影奖。
This was his Emmy winning submission.
这是他获得艾美奖的作品。
And when you watch this one, it really looks beautiful.
当你看到这个的时候，它看起来真的很漂亮。
The night stuff outside of New York Street and the ending we just talked about, it's really quite moving to look at.
纽约街外的夜晚以及我们刚才讲的结局，真的是非常让人感动。
It's a beautiful, beautifully shot episode.
这是一个美丽的、拍摄精美的剧集。
It's also hard, I don't think people understand, it's hard to get cameras into a limo and it's hard to light a limo.
这也很难，我认为人们不理解，很难将相机放入豪华轿车中，也很难点燃豪华轿车。
Like, there were technical challenges.
比如，存在技术挑战。
It's really hard.
真的很难。
That was triumphant in this episode and people don't understand.
这在这一集中取得了胜利，但人们不理解。
I don't think the- Truly, and I will say the irony, We should say, I mean, we've sort of summarized the episode.
我不认为-真的，我会说讽刺的是，我们应该说，我的意思是，我们已经对这一事件进行了总结。
It's our big New Year's Eve episode.
这是我们除夕夜的重头戏。
Ted rents a limo to try to steal back a good New Year's from what is a sea of terrible New Year's Eve.
泰德租了一辆豪华轿车，试图从可怕的除夕之海中偷回一个美好的新年。
New Year's Eve's are often terrible, as Ted says to the coat check girl, and okay, awesome, when they're listening stuff, that's supposed to be fun, that is not.
新年前夜通常很糟糕，正如泰德对衣帽寄存女孩说的那样，好吧，太棒了，当他们在听东西时，这应该很有趣，但事实并非如此。
New Year's Eve, which is a wonderful sort of setup for Ted saying, okay, we're taking back New Year's Eve tonight, we're gonna make this one fun.
新年前夜，这对特德来说是一个美妙的安排，他说，好吧，我们今晚要重新过新年前夜，我们会让这个变得有趣。
And he tries to do that for his group of friends, but there's this element of Robin dating this new guy who's super rich, and Ted has a date that night, and Ted's date sort of goes away, says you're in love with Robin, which is a great thing to hear in episode 11, the dead middle point of season one, for the wear of the rest of season one's going.
他试图为他的一群朋友做到这一点，但是罗宾和一个超级富有的新人约会的元素，那天晚上泰德有一个约会，泰德的约会有点消失了，说你爱上了罗宾，这是在第 11 集中听到的一件很棒的事情，第一季的中间点，因为第一季的其余部分都会继续下去。
She leaves, and then Ted and Robin is something gonna happen.
她离开了，然后泰德和罗宾就会发生一些事情。
No, the billionaire guy comes back, finds Robin.
不，亿万富翁回来了，找到了罗宾。
He wasn't supposed to be available that night, kind of gets in Ted's way, but then Ted and Robin have this wonderful moment at the end that promises more.
那天晚上他本来不应该在场，这有点妨碍了泰德，但泰德和罗宾在最后度过了这个美好的时刻，预示着更多。
I will say the ones, all of that summary to say, We tried to make an episode that was simple to shoot.
我想说的是，所有这些总结都是为了说，我们试图制作一集易于拍摄的剧集。
That was how this idea came about.
于是就有了这个想法。
We had been asking, we've been asking so much of the crew.
我们一直在问，我们一直在向工作人员提出很多要求。
We had been spending too much money.
我们花了太多钱。
We had been doing so many 60, 70 episodes that our wonderful producer, Susie Greenberg, who's praises, we were just singing earlier today.
我们已经制作了 60 到 70 集，以至于我们出色的制片人苏西·格林伯格（Susie Greenberg）称赞我们今天早些时候唱歌。
And Pam Fryman and everybody made these episodes happen.
帕姆·弗莱曼和每个人都促成了这些事件的发生。
And we said, here's our gift to you.
我们说，这是我们给你的礼物。
We're just gonna make an episode mostly in this limo.
我们只是要在这辆豪华轿车中制作一集。
Everybody's together for the most part.
大多数时候大家都在一起。
You're welcome, it's so simple.
不客气，就这么简单。
And by the end of shooting this episode, everybody was like, fuck you guys.
在这一集拍摄结束时，每个人都说，操你们这些家伙。
You made, this was the hardest one to shoot.
你做到了，这是最难拍摄的。
It was hard.
这很难。
And I run a little claustrophobic.
我有点幽闭恐惧症。
You know, like it was just, it was a real, I remember on breaks when we would have a moment to step out and we'd be like, oh, you know, coming out of the.
你知道，就像这只是，这是一个真实的，我记得在休息时，当我们有时间走出去时，我们会说，哦，你知道，走出去。
Yeah, correct me if I'm wrong.
是的，如果我错了，请纠正我。
We drove a limo into the sound stage, made it certain poor man's process as they say, right, just black out the windows and shot it on a soundstage mostly.
我们开着一辆豪华轿车进入摄影棚，就像他们所说的那样，把它做成了穷人的过程，对吧，只是把窗户关上，然后在摄影棚里拍摄。
Only the exterior limo stuff is actually shot on exterior near your street, but the limo that we were shooting in was the same limo question mark, or was it a special limo where it was tricked out to have a different limo where seats lifted out and walls lifted out?
只有外部豪华轿车的东西实际上是在您所在街道附近的外部拍摄的，但我们拍摄的豪华轿车是同一个豪华轿车问号，或者它是一辆特殊的豪华轿车，它被设计成有一辆不同的豪华轿车，座椅升起，墙壁升起？
I'm sure it was something clever like that, but god damn it, I can't remember.
我确信这是一件很聪明的事，但该死的，我不记得了。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
I wasn't on set that way.
我当时不在片场。
I do have memory of an actual limo being in stage 22.
我确实记得第 22 赛段有一辆真正的豪华轿车。
Like we shot.
就像我们拍摄的那样。
So all the stuff that was inside was shot inside a sound stage in this limo.
所以里面的所有东西都是在这辆豪华轿车的摄影棚里拍摄的。
I don't know if it would have, it was probably a special limo where stuff moved in and out and then the limo that actually you see exterior on the street was not that limo because it was just a normal limo that actually drove and didn't have seats lifted.
我不知道是否会有，这可能是一辆特殊的豪华轿车，东西可以进出，然后你在街上看到的实际上的豪华轿车并不是那辆豪华轿车，因为它只是一辆普通的豪华轿车，实际上可以行驶，并且没有升降座椅。
But it was incredibly complicated as it turned out.
但事实证明，事情非常复杂。
Yeah, like I said, it became a kind of shorthand, like, well, would you rather go back to the limo?
是的，就像我说的，它变成了一种速记，就像，好吧，你愿意回到豪华轿车吗？
It's like, it was supposed to be simpler.
就像，它应该更简单。
We were a little scarred by it, but I mean, scarred relative to, you know, still a good job.
我们对此感到有点伤痕累累，但我的意思是，伤痕累累相对于，你知道，仍然是一份好工作。
But I do think you picked up in here the runner of Ted and his schedule.
但我确实认为您在这里了解了特德的跑步者和他的日程安排。
You know, he's like needing to plan his needing to have the like, no, no, no, we're intended to end 45, we're supposed to be at this party.
你知道，他就像需要计划他需要有类似的事情，不，不，不，我们打算结束 45，我们应该参加这个聚会。
But the one person he will deviate from and improvise and go into like, well, let's see what happens is Robin, he will throw, he will tear up the schedule, he will he will chew the schedule and swallow it if robin calls yes yeah which his date very much picks up on by the end yeah it's poor date it was the hugger and guess she's very sweet about it but she's like you're in love with robin and it was just really exciting to hear someone say that to Ted's face in that moment on New Year's Eve it was it I loved that moment because it was like well yeah that's what the rest of the season is going to be about and I thought that was uh I thought it was so funny when he denies it she says you clearly in love with robin And he's like, no, and he's very sincere.
但他会偏离并即兴发挥的一个人，就像，好吧，让我们看看会发生什么是罗宾，他会扔掉，他会撕毁日程表，他会咀嚼日程表并将其吞下，如果罗宾说“是的”，他的约会对象到最后都会接受，是的，这是一个糟糕的约会，这是拥抱者，我猜她对此很甜蜜，但她就像你爱上了罗宾，听到有人这么说真的很令人兴奋泰德在新年前夜那一刻的表情是我喜欢的那一刻，因为这就像是的，这就是本季剩余时间的内容，我想那是呃，我认为当他否认时，这很有趣，她说你显然爱上了罗宾，他说，不，他非常真诚。
She says, and it's clear she's, she's into you too.
她说，很明显她也喜欢你。
And he's like, wait, really?
他说，等等，真的吗？
Like he can't play that so great.
就像他不能打得那么​​好一样。
He can't not get there.
他不能不去那里。
He's so funny and he's yelling at everybody else for daring to deviate from the schedule.
他很有趣，还对其他胆敢偏离时间表的人大喊大叫。
But anything you're right, anything related to Robin, he's like, all right, we're off book here.
但只要你是对的，任何与罗宾有关的事情，他都会说，好吧，我们不在这里了。
Just a shout out to Kathleen Perkins, who played Mary Beth the hugger, the hugging coworker, who was so wonderful.
向凯瑟琳·帕金斯致敬，她扮演拥抱者玛丽·贝丝，拥抱同事，她太棒了。
And also, if you've ever seen the dev show episodes, She was at like a network executive, or like the head of the, yeah.
而且，如果你看过开发节目剧集，她就像一个网络主管，或者像一个负责人，是的。
She was so unbelievably funny in that.
她在这方面真是令人难以置信的有趣。
I remember years later just seeing her crush that show.
我记得几年后才看到她迷恋那个节目。
She was fantastic.
她太棒了。
And had clearly encountered a bunch of executives.
而且分明是遇到了一群高管。
Like she understood the essence of that, yeah.
就像她明白其中的本质一样，是的。
But I thought it was really funny.
但我觉得这真的很有趣。
I was like, well, she hugs me a lot.
我当时想，好吧，她经常拥抱我。
Maybe that means she's into me.
也许这意味着她喜欢我。
She just, she's constitutionally incapable of not hugging people.
她只是，她天生就不能不拥抱人。
She has to hug everybody.
她必须拥抱每个人。
Yeah, it's her thing.
是的，这是她的事。
Yeah, she was great.
是的，她很棒。
And we should say JP Manu as not Moby was great and iconic in this episode.
我们应该说 JP 马努（JP Manu）而不是莫比（Moby）在这一集中是伟大和标志性的。
Not Moby has stuck in the culture, I think.
我认为莫比并没有融入这种文化。
Hey, can you tell the story?
嘿，你能讲故事吗？
Don't you have a real life story about the sort of intersection of reality?
难道你没有一个关于现实交集的真实故事吗？
Well, I know Moby a bit.
嗯，我对莫比有一点了解。
I mean, if you live in L.A.
我的意思是，如果你住在洛杉矶
long enough, you get to know Moby.
时间足够长，你就会了解莫比。
He's the Richard Kind of L.A.
他是洛杉矶的理查德
He's just, he's around.
他只是，他就在附近。
He wasn't Richard Kind also the Richard Kind of L.A.
他不是理查德·金德，也不是洛杉矶的理查德·金德。
But I ended up I used to go to the East parties when he lived not far from me But then we both moved not long after like three doors down from him So I he was my neighbor I would see him, you know We'd be walking dogs and just have a conversation, but I remember at some point I said hey Do you get do people ever tell you about this how I met your mother episode?
但我最终我过去常去东方派对，当时他住得离我不远，但不久之后我们就搬到了离他三扇门的地方所以我他是我的邻居我会见到他，你知道我们会遛狗，只是聊聊，但我记得在某个时刻我说嘿你有没有人告诉过你我是如何认识你母亲的这一集？
And he was like yeah all the time And it's funny because when people run into him, I'm sure they're like are you Moby or not Moby?
他一直都说是的，这很有趣，因为当人们遇到他时，我确信他们会问你是莫比还是不是莫比？
But he definitely was feeling the I don't think it was a burden, but I think he was feeling like yeah I know this episode is out there.
但他肯定感觉到了，我不认为这是一种负担，但我认为他的感觉是，我知道这一集就在那里。
I don't know if he'd ever seen it, but I think he had pieced together what what the gist was It's hilarious.
我不知道他是否看过，但我认为他已经拼凑出了要点是什么，这太搞笑了。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
What what does that mean?
这是什么意思？
Why are people saying the phrase not Moby to me?
为什么人们对我说的不是莫比这句话？
Where did you come up with like how how Moby and not Steven Tyler?
你是从哪里想出像莫比而不是史蒂文·泰勒这样的想法的？
Like where did that come from?
就像那是从哪里来的？
I think it was just that we thought it had to be a guy that you could you could You could conceivably get it wrong.
我认为这只是我们认为它必须是一个你可以你可以你可以想象错的人。
Do you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like, Moby had, you do sometimes see guys that look like Moby, right?
就像，莫比，你有时确实会看到看起来像莫比的人，对吧？
You had that just, Alec Love, our producer.
我们的制作人亚历克·洛夫（Alec Love）就是这样。
Alec looks like Moby.
亚历克看起来像莫比。
You could look like Moby, you got the glasses on, you got the sort of like hipster track jumpers.
你可以看起来像莫比，你戴上眼镜，你就像时髦的田径运动员。
I'm not saying that's what Moby in real life does now, but for a certain time, in the late 90s or early 2000s, there was a very iconic Moby look.
我并不是说现实生活中的 Moby 就是这么做的，但在 90 年代末或 2000 年代初的某个时期，Moby 的外观非常具有标志性。
There he is, Alex replicating, it was glasses.
他就在那里，亚历克斯复制着，那​​是眼镜。
And I think it was just, we were pitching on, who could you plausibly really get into a memo spend a bunch of time with before realizing it's not that person and it just Moby was somehow it was just the platonic ideal idea just was perfect do you know how it's like we were talking in the last episode like the pineapple was the perfect fruit and Moby was the perfect rock star for this rock star yeah oh no some yeah if you spend enough time and you have to sit around for like half a day in a writer's room just pitching on stuff and to land at Moby or to land at Pine Apple and you go I can't believe this is what I'm doing with my life I can't be paid to do this to talk for half a day about who's the best person and like five hours and it's like Moby.
我认为这只是，我们在推销，你能花很多时间和谁一起写一份备忘录，然后才意识到不是那个人，只是莫比不知何故，这只是柏拉图式的理想想法，很完美你知道吗，就像我们在上一集中谈论的那样，菠萝是完美的水果，而莫比是这个摇滚明星的完美摇滚明星是的，哦，不，是的，如果你花足够的时间，你必须坐上半天在作家的房间里，只是推销一些东西，然后登陆莫比或登陆松苹果，然后你就走了，我不敢相信这就是我一生所做的事情，我不能拿钱来做这件事，花半天时间谈论谁是最好的人，大约五个小时，这就像莫比。
And but then you're glad you spent the time because not Moby was I don't think we could have beaten it.
但你会很高兴你花了时间，因为不是莫比，我认为我们无法击败它。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
It's perfection.
这是完美的。
Yeah.
是的。
And it also it also like it made me feel again almost like the balance of action song.
它也让我再次感觉像是动作歌曲的平衡。
It made me feel like we're on a show of the moment.
这让我感觉我们正在表演一场当下的表演。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like we're not on a show that's like talking about Lawrence Welk.
就好像我们不是在谈论劳伦斯·韦尔克的节目一样。
Like we're were like really, were really happening in real time.
就像我们真的、真的实时发生一样。
And now it's a period piece.
现在它是一个时代作品。
Like now it feels like, okay, we look back.
就像现在的感觉，好吧，我们回顾一下。
That was 2005.
那是2005年。
There are a couple of things I wanted to, that just delighted me that I just wanted to say.
有几件事我想说，让我很高兴，我只想说。
Barney C.D.
巴尼 C.D.
is hilarious.
很搞笑。
And the fact that it should rise and fall, but no, it should just rise and rise and rise.
事实上，它应该上涨和下跌，但不，它应该只是上涨、上涨、上涨。
And that not Moby agrees with him.
莫比并不同意他的观点。
Oh, when they link up about it and not Moby is saying insightful things about music.
哦，当他们联系起来时，莫比并不是在谈论有关音乐的深刻见解。
It's like, clearly this is Moby, he's a music guy.
显然，这就是莫比，他是一个音乐人。
He knows everything about music.
他了解音乐的一切。
He's like, he's second and burn.
他就像，他是第二并且燃烧。
But, yeah, would say it hard to get the rights to, you give love a bad name?
但是，是的，你会说很难获得权利，你给爱带来了坏名声吗？
Is that what the song's called?
这首歌叫这个名字吗？
First of all, yeah, that's the song.
首先，是的，这就是这首歌。
You give a little bad name.
你给起的名字有点不好。
First of all, I think it's the most we've ever played a song in an episode, because that song starts and stops like 14 times.
首先，我认为这是我们在一集中播放歌曲次数最多的一次，因为这首歌开始和停止了 14 次。
I think you have to pay more for that.
我认为你必须为此付出更多。
I wish this would be a good Andy Gamone question.
我希望这是一个很好的安迪·加莫内问题。
If we ever talked to our music supervisor, Andy Gamone, I think you probably text her.
如果我们曾经和我们的音乐总监安迪·加莫内（Andy Gamone）交谈过，我想你可能会发短信给她。
You're like, we're gonna play it 15 times.
你说，我们要玩 15 次。
Is that okay?
可以吗？
I think there's probably an upcharge there.
我认为那里可能有加价。
But it was expensive.
但价格昂贵。
It was probably our most expensive one today, where it's a Bon Jovi.
这可能是我们今天最贵的一款，是 Bon Jovi。
It's an absolute classic Bon Jovi song.
这是一首绝对经典的 Bon Jovi 歌曲。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
It was a lot of money.
这是很多钱。
But you wanna know something talking about spending half a day debating Moby.
但你想知道一些关于花半天时间辩论莫比的事情。
I cannot tell you how much of a debate there was about what song this should be.
我无法告诉你关于这首歌应该是什么的争论有多少。
It had to be a song that right when you hit play, it's just all the way in.
它必须是一首当你点击播放时，它就一直在播放的歌曲。
It's all the way in.
都是一路进去的
There's no slow build.
没有缓慢的构建。
There's no intro piece.
没有介绍片。
It's right.
是的。
It has to be a song that starts And Phil Lord and I, it's probably the closest we've come to actually having discord in our relationship because Phil Lord, whom I adore, Lord Miller, they were writers on the show on season one, Phil was going to die on the hill of any way you want it by a journey, is that what that song's called?
这必须是一首开头的歌，菲尔·洛德和我，这可能是我们关系中最接近真正不和谐的一首歌，因为菲尔·洛德，我崇拜的人，米勒勋爵，他们是第一季节目的编剧，菲尔将在旅途中以任何你想要的方式死在山上，那首歌是这么叫的吗？
You know when you, the song comes in, it's like, any way you want, yeah, that's what, yeah.
你知道，当你听到这首歌时，就像，任何你想要的方式，是的，就是这样，是的。
And it comes in so hot, just like shot through the heart.
它进来时如此炽热，就像射穿心脏一样。
Like it comes, it's another song that comes in like that.
就像它来的那样，这是另一首这样的歌曲。
got whittled down to this like death match between those two songs.
被缩减为这两首歌之间的死亡竞赛。
And we were almost shouting at each other about like, and I was of the moment, Bon Jovi, you know, I was like a teenager preteen at that moment.
我们几乎互相大喊大叫，而我当时就是，邦乔维，你知道，那一刻我就像一个青春期前的青少年。
That song just hit at that point for me much more than journey was, you know, 10, 15 years before that.
那首歌对我来说比10、15年前的旅程更加触动。
And so I think I think I might have made the final call, like it's got to be, it's got to be done.
所以我想我可能已经做出了最后的决定，就像它必须如此，它必须完成。
I do remember in the network run through, I think Dave Bakers was was just pressing play every time you know off and I do remember it killing like it's funny every time and it gets funnier and it's also like when Kobe starts singing it when Robin's been singing it trying to amp up the car is so funny that would be also a good Andy Galant we should have Andy Galant on to talk about we should do an Andy Galant episode it'd be very funny to say when when Robin starts singing it was that another 15,000 How much did we pay for that?
我确实记得在网络播放中，我认为戴夫·贝克斯只是在每次你知道的时候按下播放键，我确实记得它每次都很有趣，而且变得更有趣，而且就像科比开始唱歌而罗宾在唱歌时试图放大汽车一样，这也是一个很好的安迪·加兰特，我们应该让安迪·加兰特谈论我们应该做一个安迪·加兰特集，当罗宾开始唱歌时说它是非常有趣的那另外 15,000 我们为此付了多少钱？
Yeah, how much did we pay for her just to sing it?
是啊，我们为她唱这首歌花了多少钱？
Yeah, I think you have to.
是的，我想你必须这样做。
I think it's, yeah, we got to ask him that.
我想，是的，我们必须问他这个问题。
I'm almost positive we would have had to pay for that too.
我几乎肯定我们也必须为此付出代价。
But it's just, it's the perfect song.
但这只是一首完美的歌曲。
It comes in on 11.
11号到货。
It just comes in, it comes in in the red.
它刚刚进来，它是红色的。
Yeah, well also there's music, like needle drops, which is an industry term, but they're so important.
是的，还有音乐，比如针滴，这是一个行业术语，但它们非常重要。
It's so important, sometimes you can introduce a song like you love, like not a surf, which maybe a lot of people hadn't heard.
这非常重要，有时你可以介绍一首你喜欢的歌曲，比如不是冲浪，这可能很多人没有听过。
This is one, it's dependent on it being in the cultural bloodstream for 20 years.
这就是其中之一，它取决于它在文化血液中融入了20年。
You need something that everyone, that's part of the comedy about it, is it's just like, it just does the thing it's supposed to do, and it also does it at moments that it's inappropriate.
你需要每个人都知道的东西，这是喜剧的一部分，就像它只是做了它应该做的事情，而且它也在不合适的时刻做了它。
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, there's when there's like the awkward sort of downbeat silence and then it pops in again.
哦，有时候会出现一种尴尬的悲观沉默，然后又突然出现。
That was a laugh out loud moment for me watching it.
那一刻对我来说是一个大笑的时刻。
And also that Barney's entire psyche is like as soon as that CD is to get like mixed goes away, he becomes Emily Dickinson.
而且巴尼的整个心灵就像是一旦那张混合的 CD 消失了，他就变成了艾米莉·狄金森。
He doesn't have any where he just spirals into darkness, which is almost like it's his drug for the night.
他没有任何地方可以让他陷入黑暗，这几乎就像是他夜晚的毒品。
Like it's his way to stay psyched.
好像这是他保持精神状态的方式。
And once he has it, he falls into an existential pit.
一旦他拥有了它，他就会陷入存在主义的深渊。
So is this the first Ranji reappearance since the pilot?
这是自试播集以来兰吉首次回归吗？
Yes, Ranji appeared in two episodes in season one episode one pilot episode 11 the lima.
是的，兰吉在第一季第一集试播集第 11 集《利马》中出现过两集。
Okay, there it is Wow, it's so funny how sometimes characters like loom large in the psyche of the show But like yeah, I mean, it's amazing that he was only on two He has so much presence.
好吧，就是这样哇，有时候像这样的角色在节目的灵魂中显得很重要，这真是太有趣了但是就像是的，我的意思是，令人惊讶的是他只在两个人身上他有如此多的存在。
He's just present on screen and he was also the kindest sweetest human like every time I'm you were never not delighted to see Marshall come on set.
他只是出现在银幕上，他也是最善良、最可爱的人，就像每次我在场时你都会很高兴看到马歇尔出现在片场一样。
He was so wonderful.
他真是太棒了。
I also love, I don't want you to see me pissed.
我也爱，我不想让你看到我生气。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I don't want his to be pissed, Ted.
我不想让他生气，特德。
It's so great.
太棒了。
He's like, he struck up a friendship.
他就像，他建立了友谊。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
He's a gentleman.
他是一位绅士。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Was Ranjit driving for the limo company and Ted found him?
兰吉特是豪华轿车公司的司机，泰德找到了他吗？
Did Ted rent a limo and hire Ranjit to be the driver?
特德是否租了一辆豪华轿车并聘请兰吉特担任司机？
Like, how does this work?
比如，这是如何工作的？
And how did Ted track him down?
泰德是怎么找到他的？
Do we just assume at the end of that champagne night, they were like, let's all stay in touch.
我们是否可以假设在那个香槟之夜结束时，他们会说，让我们保持联系吧。
Yeah, let's all stay in touch.
是的，让我们都保持联系。
They probably let's let's all buy a bar type of moment.
他们可能会让我们都买一个酒吧式的时刻。
I think, yeah, it's definitely strongly implied that Ranchi now drives for the limo company too, because he says, I'm moving up in the world.
我想，是的，这绝对强烈暗示兰契现在也为豪华轿车公司开车，因为他说，我正在世界上晋升。
He's moving up from cab to driving a big old limo for special events.
他正在从出租车升级到驾驶一辆大型老式豪华轿车来参加特殊活动。
A couple other things.
还有其他一些事情。
This is the first time I ever heard the phrase, and I love it, but when Lily said these dogs are barking, was that a Courtney Kain line?
这是我第一次听到这个短语，我喜欢它，但是当莉莉说这些狗在吠叫时，这是考特尼·凯恩的台词吗？
I feel like that might have been a Courtney Kain line.
我觉得这可能是考特尼·凯恩的台词。
That is an old, that phrase pre-exists.
这是一个古老的短语，这个短语已经存在了。
That is my new hero.
那是我的新英雄。
No, I know it existed.
不，我知道它存在。
But I've never heard it before.
但我以前从未听说过。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Was did Courtney pitch it?
是考特尼推销的吗？
I can see Courtney pitching that.
我可以看到考特尼在推销这一点。
God, I can't remember.
天哪，我不记得了。
I love these dogs.
我喜欢这些狗。
I love when Lily would just say weird shit, like these dogs are barking.
我喜欢莉莉说些奇怪的话，就像这些狗在吠叫。
These dogs are barking, yeah.
这些狗在吠叫，是的。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Natalia is great.
娜塔莉亚很棒。
The drunk.
醉酒者。
Very funny.
很搞笑。
I super love you.
我超级爱你。
She was, she, I mean, sometimes guest stars.
她，我的意思是，有时客串明星。
It's actually very hard to guest star on a show Because we, the five of us, we live there, right?
客串节目其实很难，因为我们五个人住在那里，对吧？
They're coming into our house.
他们要进我们家了
We know the whole crew, it's the warmth that you feel and the ease and comfort you feel when you're a series regular is so different than what a guest art feels.
我们了解整个剧组，当你成为剧集常客时，你感受到的温暖、轻松和舒适与客串艺术的感受有很大不同。
They get cast very quickly.
他们很快就被铸造了。
They go into a wardrobe fitting.
他们进入衣柜试穿。
They're on to that.
他们正在做这件事。
Maybe the next, that afternoon or the next day or two days later, maybe they haven't even been, I don't remember.
也许是第二天，那天下午，或者第二天或两天后，也许他们甚至没有去过，我不记得了。
I don't think she was at the run-through.
我不认为她在演练中。
I think she got cast later.
我想她是后来才被选上的。
So I'm always amazed when actors can come on and just crush it as a guest star.
所以当演员们能够以客串明星的身份出场并碾压它时，我总是感到惊讶。
Because you're really coming in.
因为你真的要进来了。
I remember someone said, here's what guest starring in law and order is like, it's like, I'm unloading groceries.
我记得有人说过，这就是《法律与秩序》客串的样子，就像，我在卸杂货。
My wife is dead?
我老婆死了？
Like you just have to pivot from this insane, like, banal task to the most emotional thing.
就像你必须从这种疯狂、平庸的任务转向最情绪化的事情。
And the series regulars are just like, that's right, your wife is dead.
系列常客就像，没错，你的妻子死了。
Like they get to be stoic.
就像他们变得坚忍一样。
and kind of, you know, chill, right?
有点，你知道，冷静，对吧？
Yeah, it's really hard to fly in and do that.
是的，飞进去做这些真的很难。
And this was a great episode for that, right?
这是一个很棒的插曲，对吧？
Those, everybody in this episode was great.
这一集中的每个人都很棒。
And then it needed to be, because everyone's stuck in a fucking limo.
然后就必须如此，因为每个人都被困在他妈的豪华轿车里。
I love that it's an episode about New Year's Eve parties, and you don't see one second of a single New Year's Eve party.
我喜欢这是关于除夕派对的一集，而且你看不到任何除夕派对的一秒钟。
It's very like Rose and Krantz and Guildenstern are dead, like the Hamlet stories happening somewhere else.
就好像罗丝、克兰兹和吉尔登斯特恩都死了一样，就像哈姆雷特的故事发生在其他地方一样。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
Well, also, you know, the thing about New Year's Eve being miserable, like, this is another thing where the what was actually happening in the fictional world was mirroring what was happening in our world.
嗯，还有，你知道，关于新年前夜的事情是悲惨的，就像，这是另一件事，虚构世界中实际发生的事情反映了我们世界中发生的事情。
Like we weren't happy in that limo, like it started to feel incredibly claustrophobic.
就像我们在那辆豪华轿车里不开心一样，就像它开始让人感觉难以置信的幽闭恐惧症。
You needed to get out and stretch your legs and it was just it was just it was just like a pressure.
你需要出去伸展一下双腿，但这就像一种压力。
It must have been hot in there too.
那里一定也很热。
It was lightning in your face and your maybe and I wonder if that's why because I did one okay I have one ding.
闪电击中你的脸，你的也许，我想知道这是否就是为什么，因为我做得很好，但我却听到了叮当声。
I like to give notes on the episodes when I watch them now and no one was dressed warmly enough for New Year's Eve in New York.
当我现在看这些剧集时，我喜欢对这些剧集做笔记，因为纽约的新年前夜没有人穿得足够暖和。
It felt a little LA, it felt a little LA, right?
感觉有点洛杉矶，感觉有点洛杉矶，对吧？
There was an evidence of big bulky jackets, and then like even what they were wearing, maybe the jackets were all in a corner somewhere of the limo in a pile maybe, but even what they're wearing like Robins in this like sleeveless, like it's like the whole time, like they would be so fucking freezing.
有证据表明他们穿着大而笨重的夹克，然后就像他们穿的衣服一样，也许这些夹克都堆在豪华轿车的某个角落里，但即使他们穿着像罗宾斯这样的无袖衣服，就像一直以来，就像他们会他妈的那么冷。
But I thought part of it is how hot it was in that limo, and wardrobe is like, they're gonna be sweating balls in there if we put them all in sweaters and shit.
但我认为部分原因是那辆豪华轿车里有多热，而且衣柜就像，如果我们把他们都穿上毛衣和狗屎，他们会在里面大汗淋漓。
I'm almost sure we had that conversation, and I'm almost sure that was a consideration.
我几乎可以肯定我们进行过那次谈话，而且我几乎可以肯定这是一个考虑因素。
Like we, and you don't want to have bulky jackets that you're carrying in and out of the car.
像我们一样，您不想携带笨重的夹克进出汽车。
I think we just made a game time decision, like we're not gonna, and also the planet, yeah, wasn't as warm as it is now.
我想我们只是做出了比赛时间的决定，就像我们不会那样，而且地球，是的，不像现在那么温暖。
So.
所以。
It would have been cold.
天气会很冷。
I was watching her throw back on and she was like, no, I call bullshit.
我看着她重新站起来，她说，不，我称之为胡说八道。
They would be much more mumbled after us again.
他们会再次在我们身后咕哝。
Do you know what made me laugh, which was something that, I can't remember who was the big champion of this.
你知道是什么让我发笑吗？我不记得谁是这场比赛的最大冠军了。
I think Jason was in on this, but we had this the whole nine years.
我认为杰森也参与其中，但我们已经这样度过了整整九年。
but when the car stops, we would go like that.
但当车停下来时，我们就会那样走。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
And I noticed there was one that I kind of missed.
我注意到有一个我有点想念的地方。
Like I was like, oh yeah, we're supposed to, but everyone was really into doing it.
就像我当时想的那样，哦，是的，我们应该这样做，但每个人都真的很喜欢这样做。
But I always thought it was silly because you're not going that fast.
但我一直认为这很愚蠢，因为你不会走得那么快。
It's New York City, right?
这是纽约市，对吧？
Like you're going 15 miles an hour and you stop.
就像你以每小时 15 英里的速度行驶然后停下来。
You don't burn a bumper driver.
你不会烧掉保险杠司机。
But everyone was really into doing it.
但每个人都非常热衷于这样做。
And it was just like this funny little joke that is not that funny in the episode.
就像这个有趣的小笑话在剧集中并不那么好笑。
It's just, it was funny on set.
只是，片场很有趣。
You know, it's almost getting like getting the general It's trying to get the general.
你知道，这几乎就像是要得到将军一样，它正在试图得到将军。
Yeah, it's really right.
是的，确实是对的。
Yeah, that's really funny I love those things that could become runners over nine years just just in your own mind as actors like you You guys are working in guys guys guys a lot for a while because Michael Shai always used to say guys guys guys You're like if there's just the word guys in the script you would always change it to guys guys guys guys To our AD Michael yeah, this is a sentence that I don't think had ever been uttered on on national television before, but I think we were the first to say, hell of a woman, let's go get some hot dogs.
是的，这真的很有趣，我喜欢那些可以在九年里成为跑步者的东西，只是在你自己的脑海里，作为像你这样的演员，你们在伙计们工作了一段时间，因为迈克尔·谢伊总是习惯说伙计们，伙计们，如果剧本中只有“伙计们”这个词，你总是会把它改成“伙计们，伙计们”，对我们的广告来说，迈克尔是的，这句话我认为以前从未在国家电视台上说过，但我想我们是第一个说的，真是个女人，我们去买点热狗吧。
Right?
正确的？
It's such a weird turn.
这真是一个奇怪的转变。
Hell of a woman.
一个女人的地狱。
He says it's very cold hell of a woman.
他说女人真是太冷酷了。
You know, in some ways, Marshall's entire personalities encapsulated in that whole line.
你知道，在某些方面，马歇尔的整个个性都集中在这整条路线中。
So he's got like his romantic kind of like, I love this woman and I'm gonna always be here for her.
所以他有一种浪漫的感觉，我爱这个女人，我会永远在她身边。
And also, god damn it, let's get those hot dogs.
还有，该死的，我们去吃热狗吧。
I love after that moment, the cut to the next scene is him saying, wow, we're riding around in a limo eating hot dogs.
我喜欢那一刻之后，下一个场景的切入是他说，哇，我们坐在豪华轿车里吃热狗。
It's like we're the president.
就好像我们是总统一样。
We're the president.
我们是总统。
But you know what the president does.
但你知道总统是做什么的。
That's now what our president does.
这就是我们总统现在所做的。
That is a 100 percent now, you know, but back then it was kind of absurd.
现在这是 100%，你知道，但在当时这有点荒谬。
But now literally like our president is in limos with Big Macs.
但现在就像我们的总统坐在豪华轿车里吃着巨无霸一样。
He's 100 percent doing that as we speak.
就在我们说话的时候，他百分百地这么做了。
old man.
老头儿。
He musted me fell in love with you.
他一定让我爱上你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials, end of commercials back to show.
现在是广告，广告结束后又回到节目中。
Okay, this is where I got to call out a, uh, this is where I got to call out a, uh, a dated thing.
好吧，这是我必须喊出一个，呃，这是我必须喊出一个，呃，一个过时的东西的地方。
And it made me laugh every time.
每次都让我发笑。
Yeah.
是的。
I can't get through the circuits are jam.
我无法通过电路堵塞。
What the fuck was happening?
到底发生了什么？
We said that so many times.
我们说过很多次了。
So many times.
这么多次。
You picture like the the old time the operator like trying to plug in the things and get the calls through.
你可以想象过去接线员喜欢尝试插入东西并接通电话。
I was like, are we radar from mash?
我当时想，我们是来自 mash 的雷达吗？
What's happening?
发生什么事了？
Are they trilikes?
他们是三样人吗？
We're trying to get to Turkey on the line and see if they've got some extra you know what this exchange maybe laughs because Marshall goes, I can't get through the circuits Mr. jammed and you made me say well that's New Year's Eve for you what the fuck was that a note or did we do did where we asked to do I got I dabbed in my skin crawl so much I'm like is it 1874 like what's happening right now uh Tony Express I can't get through the Lily Lily it's Marshall stop and then at the end there's a nice daguerreotype photograph whoosh with the big like yeah that's it's everything about those moments we're so I was sitting there going why did we act like it was I didn't I can't expect it that's it feels like it was a note that we got enough people enough wimium listeners want this I think a funny t-shirt would be I can't get through the circuits or jam circuits or jam it's like three times we've had that phrase I think it's four.
我们正试图通过电话到达土耳其，看看他们是否有一些额外的东西，你知道这次交流可能会笑什么，因为马歇尔说，我无法通过电路，卡住了，你让我说，对你来说，那是新年前夜，那张纸条到底是什么，或者我们做了我们要求做的事情吗？我得到了我的皮肤爬行如此之多，我就像是1874年就像现在正在发生的事情呃托尼快递我无法通过莉莉莉莉，马歇尔停下来，最后有一张漂亮的银版照片嗖嗖地响着，就像是的，这就是我们那些时刻的一切，所以我坐在那里思考为什么我们表现得好像是我没有我没想到那感觉就像是一张纸条，我们有足够多的人足够的 wimium 听众想要这个我想一件有趣的 T 恤会是我无法通过电路或堵塞电路或堵塞，这就像我们已经说过三次这样的短语，我想是四次。
I think it's four.
我认为是四个。
That's four.
那是四个。
I mean, it really is a runner in the thing.
我的意思是，它确实是一个跑步者。
And it really, it makes us look like we were, yeah, like, mash.
确实，这让我们看起来就像是，是的，就像，混搭。
Like it makes you look.
就像它让你看起来一样。
It's a hundred years ago.
这是一百年前的事了。
And it's like, were we so concerned that people would be like, ah, why can't they get some in a cell phone?
就像，我们是否如此担心人们会说，啊，为什么他们不能在手机中获得一些东西？
Sometimes you don't hear your ringer.
有时您听不到铃声。
The call didn't go through.
电话没有接通。
That happens now in 2025.
这将在 2025 年发生。
There was no need to explain that at any moment.
任何时候都不需要解释。
And we were like, really over explaining that one.
我们的反应是，真的过度解释了这一点。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Oh, God.
哦，上帝。
Sorry.
对不起。
Sorry, everyone.
对不起，大家。
That was a mess on our part.
对我们来说那是一团糟。
Can I ask if there was mix of broken logic with Marshall's phone?
我能问一下，马歇尔的电话是否存在逻辑混乱？
Yeah, I think there was, because I think she did.
是的，我认为有，因为我认为她有。
I think one of those, like, the circuits are, like, I think one of those, his phone was still stuck in the limo, right?
我想其中之一，就像，电路，就像，我想其中之一，他的手机还卡在豪华轿车里，对吧？
And she's, and she's still saying that stupid line when that, we didn't have to say it there.
她仍然在说那句愚蠢的台词，而我们不必在那里说。
Because anyway, I'm sorry, everyone.
因为无论如何，我很抱歉，大家。
No, no.
不，不。
I mean, these are the kind of funny things that it's almost like, you know, like famous when props get misplaced, shot to shot, like famous.
我的意思是，这些都是一些有趣的事情，你知道，就像当道具放错地方时，一个镜头接一个镜头时，就像出名一样。
in great movies, right?
在伟大的电影中，对吧？
Oh, yeah, it happens in everything.
哦，是的，一切都会发生。
It happens in everything you can't avoid it.
它发生在你无法避免的一切事情上。
I think in this one too, I think Mo, not Moby, leaves with the disc, believes with like the case of the get-ciked mix, not just the CD itself, but then all of a sudden it's back in the limo.
我认为在这一张中，我认为莫，而不是莫比，带着光盘离开，相信就像 get-ciked mix 的情况一样，不仅仅是 CD 本身，但突然它又回到了豪华轿车里。
Empty has pretty city-staking the disc.
Empty 拥有相当不错的城市赌注盘。
I think that was a glitch.
我认为这是一个小故障。
I think I remember getting called out on that and being like, yeah, that feels like weird.
我想我记得我被点名了，然后就想，是的，这感觉很奇怪。
You know, when I was editing one of my movies, I worked with this great editor both times, Michael Miller, and he had edited Raising Arizona and Ghost World and all these really incredible, yeah.
你知道，当我剪辑一部电影时，我两次与这位伟大的剪辑师迈克尔·米勒合作，他剪辑了《抚养亚利桑那》和《幽灵世界》，所有这些真的令人难以置信，是的。
Talk about editing.
谈论编辑。
Yeah.
是的。
And he did a couple of Conrad, but he was a great editor.
他还出演了几部康拉德的作品，但他是一位出色的剪辑师。
I learned a lot from him.
我从他身上学到了很多。
And we had lost a scene, we had edited out a scene, and then it made it look like they changed clothes in the middle of the day.
我们丢失了一个场景，剪辑掉了一个场景，然后看起来就像他们在中午换了衣服。
And he said to me, I'll never forget this, he said, audiences don't pay attention to that.
他对我说，我永远不会忘记这一点，他说，观众不会注意到这一点。
And do you know the Robert Redford movie, Three Days in the Condor?
你知道罗伯特·雷德福的电影《秃鹰三天》吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Originally, the original script was called Six Days in the Condor.
最初，最初的剧本被称为《秃鹰六日》。
And in editing, they were like, we need to compress the time.
在编辑过程中，他们说，我们需要压缩时间。
It works better as three days.
三天效果比较好。
And if you watch the movie in the middle of the day, they just switch.
如果你在中午看电影，他们就会切换。
They're just changing clothes.
他们只是在换衣服。
And he said, no one has ever brought it up in movie history.
他说，电影史上从来没有人提起过它。
Like no one says anything about it, which I think is an incredible thing.
就像没有人对此说任何话一样，我认为这是一件令人难以置信的事情。
Like, what are we, what are we watching and what are we paying attention to?
比如，我们是什么，我们在看什么，我们在关注什么？
You know, but I think I think some of these things like I think there's a timeless aspect to how I made your mother That is why it's so widely beloved because teenagers right now are watching it and it feels relevant to them They can relate to it's not too.
你知道，但我想我认为其中一些事情就像我认为我如何创造你的母亲有一个永恒的方面这就是为什么它如此广泛地受到喜爱，因为现在的青少年正在观看它并且感觉与他们相关他们可以理解它并不是太。
It's not so far like It's been swallowed by the past But there are these markers that it was 2005 and I think that they're sweet and cool and not to be apologized for actually No, no.
到目前为止，它还没有被过去吞没，但有这些标记表明那是 2005 年，我认为它们很甜蜜很酷，实际上不需要道歉，不，不。
It captures it.
它捕捉到了它。
And look, it's a story being told from 2030 about 2005.
看，这是一个从 2030 年到 2005 年讲述的故事。
And in 2030, you'd be looking back at it saying what we're saying right now.
到 2030 年，当你回顾过去时，你会说出我们现在所说的话。
We're in 2025 right now.
我们现在已经到了 2025 年了。
Yeah, you almost like created a context where you get away with all that.
是的，你几乎喜欢创造一个你可以逃脱所有这些的环境。
It's okay to say the year.
说一下年份就可以了。
It's okay because it's a story about that year.
没关系，因为这是那一年的故事。
What will be weird is when the real world passes 2030 if we all survive that long.
奇怪的是，当现实世界过了 2030 年时，如果我们都活了那么久的话。
Who knows?
谁知道？
TBD.
待定。
And that is going to be like, oh shit, that's adding another level of weirdness.
这就像，天啊，这又增加了一层奇怪的感觉。
But at the moment, it's still, Yeah, it's okay this that happened in that year of Ted Mosby's life.
但目前，仍然是，是的，泰德·莫斯比那一年发生的事情没关系。
Yeah, future Ted gets to talk about it Yeah, he's not gonna upgrade anyone's phones in the story.
是的，未来的特德会谈论它是的，他不会升级故事中任何人的手机。
Yeah Although I don't think anyone was saying the phrase the circuits are busy even in two that I don't remember ever saying that Well, that's New Year's Eve for you That line jumped out at me to Josh and I was like poor Josh having to say that line Well, you'll notice that I really try to make sure work of it.
是的，虽然我不认为有人说过这句话，电路很忙，即使是在两个我不记得曾经说过，好吧，那是你的除夕夜，那句话跳到了我的乔什身上，我就像可怜的乔什不得不说那句话好吧，你会注意到我真的尽力确保它的工作。
I was like well, that's what you do when you get a real clunker Yeah, you just try to act like it's you just throw it away, you know, I'm gonna look for more of those as we continue the rewatch I think if it was like the third or fourth season, I would have gone up to you and said I'm not saying this line You should have you and you damn well should have I know I was still trying to be a good student, you know I'm still trying to get the a I Why I thought you sit when mo when not Moby says I thought you said Tony and And then he says, so your name is Tony and he says, no, no, it's so funny.
我当时想，好吧，这就是你得到一个真正的旧车时所做的事情是的，你只是试着表现得好像你只是把它扔掉，你知道，当我们继续重看时，我会寻找更多这样的东西我想如果是第三季或第四季，我会走到你面前说我不是说这句话你应该拥有你，你该死的应该拥有我知道我仍在努力成为一个好学生，你知道我仍在努力获得一个我为什么我以为你坐着，而莫而不是莫比说我以为你说的是托尼，然后他说，所以你的名字是托尼，他说，不，不，这太有趣了。
He is so crazy and and we and he's wonderful that in that episode.
他太疯狂了，我们和他在那一集中表现得很出色。
And then what I love about that moment is you figure, well, that's it.
然后我喜欢那一刻的是你认为，好吧，就是这样。
We're never going to hear know this guy's name.
我们永远不会知道这个人的名字。
And then there's that wonderful way later in the episode, Marshall says Moby signs my shirt.
在这一集中，马歇尔说莫比在我的衬衫上签名，这真是太棒了。
He tries to run it says Eric on the top of the shirt.
他试图运行它，衬衫顶部写着埃里克（Eric）。
We did get to solve that mystery is the guy's name is Eric, which as you put it out Josh sounds not at all like Tony or Moby or Moby and also like just Eric it's just like really crudely drawn like it's not like a signature it's just like the guy's a proper psycho.
我们确实解开了这个谜团，这个人的名字叫埃里克（Eric），正如你所说，乔什（Josh）听起来一点也不像托尼（Tony）或莫比（Moby）或莫比（Moby），而且也像埃里克（Eric）一样，它就像是非常粗略地绘制的，就像它不像一个签名一样，就像这家伙是一个真正的疯子一样。
He's a psycho he's waving that gun around he did JP Manuke captured that unhinged energy very well.
他是个神经病，他挥舞着那把枪，JP Manuke 很好地捕捉到了那种精神错乱的能量。
Speaking of waving the gun around I did catch something I did that I thought was delightful.
说到挥舞枪，我确实发现了我所做的一些我认为令人愉快的事情。
When he's waving the gun around I hold the party schedule note card up to my head to protect me from an errant bullet.
当他挥舞枪时，我将聚会日程记事卡举到头上，以保护我免受错误子弹的伤害。
If you look, I'm holding it up like, oh, God.
如果你看的话，我举起它就像，哦，上帝。
There's a metaphor there, because Ted thinks plans will save him.
这里有一个比喻，因为泰德认为计划可以拯救他。
Plans will save everything.
计划将拯救一切。
Exactly.
确切地。
Oh, my God.
我的天啊。
So, yeah, I think it's the most we've ever played one song in the Bunch of the Song.
所以，是的，我认为这是我们在歌曲集中播放次数最多的一首歌。
I know there's probably no other episode where a song starts and stops a dozen times.
我知道可能没有其他剧集会出现一首歌开始和停止十几次的情况。
And very, I will call one other cool song out there.
非常，我会称之为另一首很酷的歌曲。
the song major leagues by pavement plays for also in a major leagues, or maybe it's just major league singular, a great song from Terry Twilight by pavement that is about being ready for great things.
《Major League by Pavement》这首歌也在大联盟中播放，或者也许这只是大联盟的单曲，一首来自 Terry Twilight by Pavement 的伟大歌曲，讲述的是为伟大的事情做好准备。
It is a great like love song that sort of talks about I'm going to screw up and I'm ready like bring on the major leagues, like bring on a real love now.
这是一首很棒的情歌，讲述的是我会搞砸，我已经准备好进入大联盟，就像现在带来真正的爱情。
And that's near the end, near the end that great ending where Ted walks off kind of into the future.
这已经接近尾声了，接近尾声了，泰德走向未来的伟大结局。
But it's sort of great because you think that's the ending song, but then it gets cut off by Robin's billionaire, hundred-millionaire boyfriend showing up and he kind of cuts off that song.
但这有点棒，因为你认为那是片尾曲，但随后罗宾的亿万富翁、亿万富翁男朋友出现就打断了这首歌，他有点切断了那首歌。
I like the kind of fake out where you think that song is kind of going to carry you through to the happy ending.
我喜欢那种假装，你认为这首歌会带你走向幸福的结局。
And it doesn't.
但事实并非如此。
It gets cut off and Ted has a bit of very bittersweet in years Eve with this little moment of hope from Robin.
它被切断了，泰德在除夕夜对罗宾的这一小小的希望感到有点苦乐参半。
But that was a little fake out ending song of pavement that didn't actually be the ending song.
但这是一首有点假的人行道结尾曲，实际上并不是结尾曲。
I like that.
我喜欢这样。
I did.
我做到了。
We talked about this, but I love the sunroof being this other playing space and I just There was something so pleasurable.
我们讨论过这个，但我喜欢天窗作为另一个游戏空间，我只是有一些如此令人愉快的事情。
Maybe it was just, I got to leave the limo, but there was something so nice about popping up and having a scene up there.
也许这只是，我必须离开豪华轿车，但突然出现并在那里观看场景真是太好了。
And also we had talked about this when Mary Beth says she can tell Robins into him and he says, wait, really?
当玛丽·贝丝说她可以告诉罗宾斯他时，我们也讨论过这个，他说，等等，真的吗？
And it occurred to me, like, Ted is a bad actor.
我突然想到，泰德是个糟糕的演员。
Like I hope I'm a good actor, but Ted is a bad actor.
就像我希望我是一个好演员，但特德是一个坏演员。
It's true.
这是真的。
He's not a master of disguise.
他不是伪装高手。
Like Barney's a pretty good actor, and most of his life is somewhat of an act or a lot of it.
就像巴尼一样，他是一位相当出色的演员，他的大部分生活都在某种程度上是在表演，或者说大部分都是在表演。
Yes.
是的。
But Ted is just, he's a guile-less, is that the word?
但特德就是这样，他很诚实，是这个词吗？
Like he's...
就像他...
He's guile-less.
他是个天真无邪的人。
Yeah.
是的。
There's no, there's no smoke screen.
不，没有烟幕。
There's nothing, he's not masking.
没什么，他没有掩饰。
He can't help himself but ask his date if she really thinks Robin likes him.
他忍不住问他的约会对象是否真的认为罗宾喜欢他。
It's that there's something so, it's sort of shitty and great at the same time because Ted just can't lie.
就是有些东西如此，它有点糟糕，但同时又很棒，因为特德就是不会说谎。
He can't cover that up.
他无法掩盖这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
that moment.
那一刻。
Great.
伟大的。
Speaking of smoke screens, I love Marshall emerging from that steam.
说到烟幕，我喜欢从烟雾中出现的马歇尔。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Lily, I'm going to go call Marshall and she just means calling his name out.
莉莉，我要去给马歇尔打电话，她只是想喊出他的名字。
That was I love when we have those little magic New York moments and that entire city he can she can call his name echoing through the buildings through the canyons of New York and he will come running out of the smoke that I love the metaphysical weirdness of New York is a very strange place.
这就是我喜欢的，当我们在纽约度过那些神奇的时刻，整个城市他可以叫他的名字，在纽约的峡谷中的建筑物中回响，他会从烟雾中跑出来，我喜欢纽约的形而上学怪异，这是一个非常奇怪的地方。
It's this intensely small village and it's one of the biggest cities in the world.
这是一个非常小的村庄，但却是世界上最大的城市之一。
all at the same time.
全部同时进行。
Oh, at the same time.
哦，同时。
Yeah.
是的。
And there's something like, if you really understand New York and the geography of at least Manhattan, that's impossible.
如果你真的了解纽约和至少曼哈顿的地理，那是不可能的。
It's impossible.
这是不可能的。
It's like, it's too loud.
就好像，声音太大了。
It's too crazy.
太疯狂了。
Like, even if he was half a block away, you can't hear someone screaming a flag away.
就像，即使他在半个街区之外，你也听不到有人在远处尖叫。
I knew you.
我认识你。
In New York City.
在纽约市。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's magic.
但这很神奇。
Like, Alec and I talk about this, like, like, just adding magic into scripts.
就像，亚历克和我谈论这个，就像，就像，只是在脚本中添加魔法。
Like Alec, I've been to tell something you told me about Fargo speaking of the Coen brothers.
和亚历克一样，我也曾告诉过你关于《冰血暴》中科恩兄弟的一些事情。
You said a female police chief investigating a murder in, where was it, Minnesota, is great, but that she's pregnant is magic, right?
你说一位女警察局长在明尼苏达州调查一起谋杀案，这很棒，但她怀孕了也很神奇，对吧？
Right.
正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
loving emerging from.
爱从中涌现。
I mean, it's almost like a professional wrestler coming out of the dressing room, like in the fog.
我的意思是，这几乎就像一个职业摔跤手从更衣室里出来一样，就像在雾中一样。
Like he, there was something he, you could tell he was in the same way, like, okay, awesome.
就像他一样，有一些东西，你可以看出他以同样的方式，就像，好吧，太棒了。
He loved the dance.
他喜欢舞蹈。
Like, he loved coming out of that.
就像，他喜欢从中走出来。
Yeah.
是的。
Now he runs, he appears out of the smoke.
现在他跑了，他出现在烟雾中。
The Bon Jovi song for the first time becomes full score.
Bon Jovi歌曲首次成为满分。
It's not being played in the limo.
这不是在豪华轿车上播放的。
It's actually the score and it plays him in.
这实际上是分数，并且让他参与其中。
And it is a very get psyched moment.
这是一个非常令人兴奋的时刻。
And Jason leaned into it.
杰森靠在了上面。
I love, I love that moment so much.
我爱，我非常爱那一刻。
And there's a third is magic like the fact that not Moby is at the same party.
第三个是神奇的，比如没有莫比参加同一个聚会。
They were gonna go to right the billion the mill hundred Millionaire finding Robin at all marshals names somehow magically calling him out of the mist His wife calling his name sort of makes him appear I feel like he was way far away from them and a portal appeared And you ran through the portal towards Lily's voice and he jumped down three floors Yeah, he jumped three floors, but Lily's voice made it all possible.
他们要去正确的亿万富翁百万富翁在所有元帅的名字中以某种方式神奇地从迷雾中呼唤他他的妻子叫他的名字有点让他出现我觉得他离他们很远并且出现了一个门户出现你穿过门户向莉莉的声音跑去他跳下了三层楼是的，他跳了三层楼但莉莉的声音使这一切成为可能。
He loves her so much.
他非常爱她。
I love that moment so much much.
我非常喜欢那一刻。
What's wonderful about this shows use of that kind of magic is that it's almost leaning on the fact that you have purchased a kind of trust from your audience to then allow to break all the rules that you have.
这个节目使用这种魔法的奇妙之处在于，它几乎依赖于这样一个事实：你已经从观众那里购买了一种信任，然后允许打破你所拥有的所有规则。
Because certainly if you mess up continuity somewhere and you're wearing the wrong clothing, you're wearing the wrong guy, that's like a ding for an audience.
因为当然，如果你在某个地方搞砸了连续性，并且你穿了错误的衣服，你穿错了人，这对观众来说就像是一个叮当声。
They'll sort of notice that if all of a sudden you just break reality and just say is that what you're saying is, do you want to have fun or not?
他们会注意到，如果你突然打破现实，只是说你所说的是，你想玩得开心吗？
Right.
正确的。
And I think that once you've got them, they love these people and they know what the show is.
我认为一旦你得到了他们，他们就会喜欢这些人并且他们知道这个节目是什么。
Oh, it's not a show that's supernatural.
哦，这不是一个超自然的节目。
This is a real life show, I'm in.
这是一场真实的表演，我参加了。
But now you're asking, hey, do you want to something crazy with me?
但现在你问，嘿，你想和我一起疯狂吗？
Come jump out a window with me and land three floors down and you had them at that point.
跟我一起从窗户跳出去，降落到三层楼下，那时你就拥有了它们。
And so you could introduce this kind of thing.
所以你可以介绍这种事情。
trust the audience to make these magical realism-based leaps, except in the case of not being able to complete a cell phone call, in which case we have to say the circuit service.
相信观众能够做出这些基于魔幻现实主义的飞跃，除非无法完成手机通话的情况，在这种情况下我们不得不说电路服务。
That one we had to explain.
我们必须解释这一点。
Marshall appearing out of the smoke, that's fine.
马歇尔从烟雾中出现，那很好。
Well, how we may, because it's this memory play, you're allowed to bend time and space and defy the laws of physics in a different way.
好吧，我们怎么可能，因为这是一种记忆游戏，你可以弯曲时间和空间，并以不同的方式挑战物理定律。
What a trick.
真是个诡计啊。
What a magic trick to get to use, is the trick of the unreliable narrator, the unreliability of memory itself.
不可靠的叙述者的伎俩，即记忆本身的不可靠，是一个多么神奇的魔术啊。
This is another magic moment, is that Marshall steals back the CD from Not Moby.
这又是一个神奇的时刻，Marshall 从 Not Moby 手中偷回了 CD。
Like one, how would he know?
就像一个人，他怎么会知道？
Like the amount of leaps that Marshall would have to make to figure out that this is Barney CD, Not Moby stole it.
就像马歇尔必须跳多少次才能弄清楚这是巴尼 CD，而不是莫比偷的。
How did you see that?
你怎么看到的？
But he thinks he's still Moby.
但他认为他仍然是莫比。
He's still thinks he's Moby.
他仍然认为自己是莫比。
But he steals it back.
但他把它偷回来了。
And it made me feel, because we get it, I don't remember when telepathy appeared, but it's one of my favorite how I made your mother jokes, is that they could speak telepathically to each other?
这让我觉得，因为我们明白了，我不记得心灵感应是什么时候出现的，但这是我最喜欢的之一，我如何让你妈妈开玩笑，他们可以通过心灵感应互相交谈吗？
Yes, they speak telepathically.
是的，他们通过心灵感应说话。
But it made me realize that like, they actually already have telepathy.
但这让我意识到，他们实际上已经有了心灵感应。
Yes.
是的。
Like they know what they need, they anticipate each other's needs, they can spit, they're sensing something about each other.
就像他们知道自己需要什么一样，他们预测彼此的需求，他们可以吐口水，他们感觉到彼此的某些东西。
They're an ecosystem or a biosphere, you know?
它们是一个生态系统或生物圈，你知道吗？
It's even better that he thought it was really Moby.
更好的是他认为这真的是Moby。
He's like, I'm stealing that thing back from Moby.
他说，我要从莫比那里把那东西偷回来。
Moby cannot steal.
莫比不能偷窃。
Moby may think he's a big, famous star, but he cannot steal my friends and get psychics.
莫比可能认为他是一个大牌、著名的明星，但他不能偷走我的朋友并获得通灵能力。
And Barney is like suddenly whole again when he gets that back.
当巴尼找回来的时候，他突然又变得完整了。
It's, yeah, I really loved rewatching this one.
是的，我真的很喜欢重看这部。
I really, this is a fun one.
我真的，这很有趣。
We didn't do a Christmas episode in season one.
我们在第一季没有制作圣诞集。
I can't quite tell you why.
我不能完全告诉你原因。
Maybe it had to do with air dates.
也许这与播出日期有关。
Maybe we just didn't have a good idea for it.
也许我们只是没有一个好主意。
We had a good idea for Thanksgiving episode and a good idea for a New Year's episode and a good idea for a Halloween episode, but we skipped Christmas.
我们对感恩节剧集有一个好主意，对新年剧集有一个好主意，对万圣节剧集也有一个好主意，但我们跳过了圣诞节。
I'm so glad we did a New Year's one.
我很高兴我们举办了新年活动。
What I loved about the comment to begin this episode, I forget her name, forgive me, I like to remember her person's name at the beginning, Andrea, from Remind me of everything about Andrea from Mexico.
我喜欢这一集开头的评论，我忘记了她的名字，请原谅我，我喜欢在开头记住她的名字，安德里亚，来自《提醒我关于墨西哥安德里亚的一切》。
Andrea from Mexico, I know, I just wanted to share what I was gonna write.
来自墨西哥的安德里亚，我知道，我只是想分享我要写的内容。
What I loved about her comment was that she says, she watches it every year right after midnight.
我喜欢她的评论的是，她说，她每年都会在午夜过后观看它。
I love that that's part of her tradition, you know what I mean?
我喜欢这是她传统的一部分，你知道我的意思吗？
That's what she hits play on that, just like starting up the Punjabi song.
这就是她演奏的内容，就像开始播放旁遮普歌曲一样。
So thank you, Andrea, sorry, I forgot your name briefly.
谢谢你，安德里亚，抱歉，我暂时忘记了你的名字。
For Mexico, your comment was amazing.
对于墨西哥，你的评论非常棒。
I love that it's part of your New Year's tradition.
我喜欢这是你们新年传统的一部分。
We didn't do too many New Year's episodes, but this one, this one was a good one.
我们没有拍太多的新年剧集，但是这一集，这一集是一部很好的。
I feel like we're actually up to the point plot-wise where Derek comes back and Ted is crushed.
我觉得我们实际上已经到了情节的关键点，德里克回来了，泰德被压垮了。
And I will say, I don't know, there was something, I really believed Ted's devastation when Derek hops in that limo.
我会说，我不知道，有一些东西，当德里克跳上那辆豪华轿车时，我真的相信泰德的毁灭。
Like there was something about my face that I was like, that was good film acting, Radner.
就像我脸上有什么东西，我觉得这就是很好的电影表演，拉德纳。
I'll see, I like hearing you say that.
我看看，我喜欢听你这么说。
I like hearing you admit that you've been good on this TV show.
我喜欢听到你承认你在这个电视节目中表现出色。
I felt like, I really felt for him.
我感觉，我真的对他有感觉。
I was like, oh, this is such a bummer for him.
我当时想，哦，这对他来说真是太糟糕了。
And the night was going particularly well, you know, for him, vis-a-vis Robin up until that point.
你知道，对于他来说，直到那时，对罗宾来说，这个夜晚都进展得特别顺利。
But I think he says the line, or maybe the narrator says all night long, I've been trying to chase something down that was right there in that limo.
但我想他说了这句话，或者也许叙述者整晚都在说，我一直在努力追寻那辆豪华轿车里的东西。
Does he say that?
他这么说吗？
Yeah, it says.
是的，它说。
And it made me think about, you know, you really watch these people from their mid to late 20s to their early to mid 30s.
这让我想到，你知道，你真的会观察这些从 20 多岁到 30 多岁的人。
That's kind of the arc.
这就是弧线的一种。
And it's a really pivotal time, that decade, 25 to 35, let's call it, is huge, right?
这是一个非常关键的时期，我们称之为 25 岁到 35 岁的十年是一个巨大的十年，对吧？
And there's a huge transition.
并且有一个巨大的转变。
And I think your 20s are really about chasing experiences.
我认为 20 多岁确实是在追求经历。
That's why it's like, we have five parties to hit.
这就是为什么我们要打五个方。
We're going out, we're gonna like go West, young man.
我们要出去，我们要去西部，年轻人。
Like we're seeking our fortune, we're seeking romance, seeking connection, you know, all of it, and it's out there, right?
就像我们在寻找财富一样，我们在寻找浪漫，寻求联系，你知道，所有这一切，它就在那里，对吧？
Everything is outside of you.
一切都在你之外。
But then maturity, I wrote this down, is realizing it's about what's inside you and what's in right in front of you, right?
但我写下来，成熟就是意识到这与你内心的东西以及你面前的东西有关，对吧？
Like it's like there's not a better life lurking out there.
好像外面没有更好的生活潜伏着。
It's like the universe is inside me and also the people I love are in front of me and it's best to be present with those people.
就好像宇宙就在我体内，我爱的人就在我面前，与这些人在一起是最好的。
So I think that in some ways that's the moral of the episode, which is like, and Ted changes, Ted learns that in that episode because he's driving them all over the city and he says, no, the best party is right here.
所以我认为在某种程度上这就是这一集的寓意，就像泰德改变了一样，泰德在那一集中了解到这一点，因为他开车带着他​​们走遍整个城市，他说，不，最好的派对就在这里。
I loved Ted in that moment when he said that.
当特德说这句话的那一刻我就爱上了他。
This is as clear an illustration of it's about the journey, not the destination because they literally never get to their destination.
这清楚地说明了这是关于旅程，而不是目的地，因为他们实际上永远不会到达目的地。
You never get out of the limo.
你永远不会离开豪华轿车。
It's all journey.
这都是旅程。
Yeah, it's all journey, but not the journey song.
是的，这都是旅程，但不是旅程之歌。
Except for the not that song.
除了不是那首歌。
Sorry for the Lord.
对不起主。
Yeah.
是的。
And to be fair, it also would have worked great.
公平地说，它也会非常有效。
To be fair.
公平地说。
No, no, I could, I could, you could make a case for that.
不，不，我可以，我可以，你可以为此提出理由。
But there's something.
但有件事。
Totally.
完全。
Because the shot through the heart really just works every time.
因为每次击中心脏确实有效。
It just pops so hard.
它实在太难弹出了。
It comes in at a million.
它的价格是一百万。
I will say that I thought the last scene with me and Kobe was pretty perfect.
我想说的是，我认为我和科比的最后一幕非常完美。
Perfect.
完美的。
The writing of it was perfect.
它的写作是完美的。
There was no fat on it.
上面没有脂肪。
it's just so simple and you have enough history fueling them at this point eleven episodes in where not much needs to be said it's like it's this you know and you could almost plausibly make the case let's say Ted thought it was a bigger deal than she did you could almost make the case like you could interpret that as romantic or not like it was actually we threaded an interesting needle there yeah it was enigmatic there was something charged to it it was there I love that moment.
就这么简单，你有足够的历史为他们提供动力，在这一点上，没有太多需要说的，就像你知道的那样，你几乎可以合理地提出这个案子，让我们说泰德认为这比她做的更重要，你几乎可以把这个案子解释成浪漫或不喜欢它实际上我们在那里穿了一根有趣的针，是的，它是神秘的，有一些东西被控在那里，我喜欢那一刻。
It tees up the entire rest of season one in the best possible way.
它以尽可能最好的方式为第一季的整个剩余比赛做好准备。
Pineapple kind of brought it back, sort of got those embers going again a little bit with Ted's recalling her and bringing this back up at him and a little bit on the back burner, the Robin thing for a while.
菠萝有点把它带回来了，有点让那些余烬再次燃烧起来，泰德回忆起了她，并把这件事带回到了他面前，有点放在次要位置，罗宾的事情暂时搁置了一段时间。
And this is bringing it back forward and this launches.
这将把它带回来并启动。
I would argue this is a really good midway point of a season episode because it really launches the second half.
我认为这是一季剧集的一个非常好的中间点，因为它真正启动了下半场。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
It also made me feel like when I was watching Ted, really through the first 11 episodes, Like, I think there's a pattern, I don't know if this is like a, if there's a term for this, but I hear from a lot of people who say, oh, I was very dear friends with my husband.
这也让我觉得，当我看《泰德》的前 11 集时，我觉得有一个模式，我不知道这是否像一个术语，但我听到很多人说，哦，我和我丈夫是非常亲密的朋友。
He was just in my friend group, but I never thought of him that way.
他只是我的朋友圈里的人，但我从来没有这样想过他。
And then you kind of like, you know, when the lights come up at the end of whatever, your age, you go, oh, this is the person I like the most and feel the most comfortable around.
然后你有点喜欢，你知道，当灯亮起时，不管你的年龄，你会说，哦，这是我最喜欢的人，在身边感觉最舒服。
I feel like Ted's kind of like the prototype for the guy, like in your friend group that a woman eventually realizes is like the best and kindest guy and falls for him.
我觉得特德有点像这个男人的原型，就像在你的朋友圈子里，一个女人最终意识到他是最好、最善良的男人，并爱上了他。
But he's easy to overlook when you're on that experience hunt, you know?
但当你在寻找经验时，他很容易被忽视，你知道吗？
You kind of don't see that guy.
你好像看不到那个人。
And I think that's what he said in his first monologue, like that monologue in the pilot.
我认为这就是他在他的第一个独白中所说的，就像飞行员中的独白一样。
Like, I'm not good at this stuff, but I'd be a really good husband.
就像，我不擅长这些，但我会是一个非常好的丈夫。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Once you realize it's not about getting the five parties, the party's right here.
一旦你意识到这不是为了获得五个聚会，聚会就在这里。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
This is it, the party is here, you know?
就是这样，聚会就在这里，你知道吗？
And I think like they get so excited like when Marshall comes back or Lily gets back, because it's like it doesn't feel right unless they're all together.
我认为他们会像马歇尔回来或莉莉回来时一样兴奋，因为除非他们在一起，否则感觉不太对劲。
And in some ways, this episode more than any other episode is the five of them are a gang, like they're an absolute gang and Robin has been fully folded in.
在某些方面，这一集比其他任何一集都更重要的是，他们五个人是一个帮派，就像他们是一个绝对的帮派，而罗宾已经完全融入其中。
So yeah, I was actually, I was pretty delighted by this episode.
所以，是的，我实际上对这一集感到非常高兴。
I remember loving the script and it being a hard shoot, but I think it endures, like I think it was worth it.
我记得我很喜欢这个剧本，而且拍摄过程很艰难，但我认为它会持续下去，就像我认为这是值得的。
We thought we were giving everyone the simplest shoot of the year, and everyone was cursing our names by the end of the week, but it was a good one.
我们以为我们给每个人带来了一年中最简单的拍摄，到了周末每个人都在咒骂我们的名字，但这是一个很好的拍摄。
So we're up to our very special section, which I think I'm gonna amend this, Alec, but I'm just now going to call this Questions and Observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother, and also happens to be married to Josh.
所以我们要讨论我们非常特别的部分，我想我要修改这个，亚历克，但我现在要把这个称为临床心理学家的问题和观察，他从未见过我是如何认识你母亲的，而且也碰巧与乔什结婚了。
I just cut out relationship expert, because I don't know, I don't know that she would describe herself that way, and I don't know that anyone could describe themselves that way.
我只是删掉了关系专家，因为我不知道，我不知道她会这样描述自己，我也不知道任何人都可以这样描述自己。
way.
方式。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
I'd be wary of a relationship expert, except Terry Reel, who's a very interesting psychologist, if you've ever listened to him.
我会对关系专家保持警惕，除了特里·里尔（Terry Reel），如果你曾经听过他的话，他是一位非常有趣的心理学家。
But he's very smart about relationships.
但他在人际关系方面非常聪明。
All right, we will amend it.
好的，我们会修改的。
We will have amended it in our graphic as you are.
我们将按照您的原样在图形中对其进行修改。
If you're watching this on YouTube, you removed and here she is the not relationship expert.
如果您在 YouTube 上观看此内容，则您已将其删除，在这里她不是关系专家。
This episode almost felt like a microcosm of a macro theme of the series, which I think is summed up by what Ted said at the very end of the episode, and I wrote it down.
这一集几乎感觉像是该系列宏观主题的缩影，我认为这是泰德在这一集最后所说的话所总结的，我把它写了下来。
So he said, you probably want to feel bad for your old man at this point in the story.
所以他说，在故事的这一点上，你可能会为你的老人感到难过。
Well, don't.
好吧，不要。
Not every night has a happy ending, but all of it's important, all of it's leading somewhere.
并不是每个夜晚都有一个美好的结局，但所有这些都很重要，所有这些都在朝着某个方向发展。
And for sitcom, this is truly a metaphysical spiritual lesson.
而对于情景喜剧来说，这确实是一堂形而上的精神课。
we make plans, the unexpected happens.
我们制定计划，意想不到的事情就会发生。
We have a small degree of control and then there's a massive amount that's beyond our control.
我们的控制程度很小，但大量的事情是我们无法控制的。
In this case, the traffic, Lily's feet hurting, Marshall forgetting his phone, not Moby, waving around a gun in the limo.
在这种情况下，交通堵塞，莉莉的脚受伤了，马歇尔忘记了他的电话，而不是莫比，在豪华轿车里挥舞着一把枪。
But the message of the episode that I took home was to have faith that whatever happens, even if it seems absolutely awful at the time.
但我带回家的这一集传达的信息是，要相信无论发生什么，即使当时看起来非常糟糕。
It is indeed all important.
这确实很重要。
It's all leading you somewhere, and that somewhere is where you belong.
这一切都会带你去某个地方，而那个地方就是你所属的地方。
And for Ted, the planner whose plans were undone, it still ultimately led to that moment that we were waiting for, that kiss with Robin.
对于特德（Ted）来说，他的计划被取消了，但最终还是导致了我们等待的那一刻，与罗宾的吻。
And though this is only Episode 11, and I have just shy of 200 more to go, my best guess is the entire show is going on fold following the spiritual lesson in a very similar way.
虽然这只是第 11 集，而且我还剩不到 200 集，但我最好的猜测是整个节目将以非常相似的方式在精神课程之后继续进行。
Wow, that's uh, but that's too good.
哇，那是呃，但这也太好了。
That's better than anything we've said so far.
这比我们迄今为止所说的任何事情都要好。
Could we just, Alex, reset it down to that one?
亚历克斯，我们可以将其重置为那个值吗？
It's just gonna be Andrea and Jordana.
只有安德里亚和乔丹娜。
Yeah, I think that's a good cut.
是的，我认为这是一个很好的剪辑。
Cut out, everybody, cut out all the dudes.
停止，大家，停止所有的家伙。
That's such a great comment.
这是一个非常棒的评论。
I love that she singled out that ending narration, and I love that idea of it's all important, which is different than saying it's all gonna work out.
我喜欢她特别提到的结尾旁白，我喜欢这种“一切都很重要”的想法，这与说一切都会成功是不同的。
I'm happy with that wording and that narration, it's true.
我对这个措辞和叙述很满意，这是真的。
It's all, it's important.
这就是全部，这很重要。
It's not all good.
这并不全是好事。
It's not all bad.
这并不全是坏事。
It's important.
这很重要。
It's important because it's part of your story and it's the accumulation of those sort of story beats of your own life that lead you where you need to be or where you want to be or where you hope to be or where you never thought you would be.
这很重要，因为它是你故事的一部分，是你自己生活中那些故事节拍的积累，引导你到达你需要去的地方、你想要去的地方、你希望去的地方、或者你从未想过你会去的地方。
But then you're happy there.
但你在那里很开心。
You know, it reminded me of something I'd read that said, like, never trust a memoir or a biography that doesn't have like some scandal in it or the protagonist doesn't look bad.
你知道，这让我想起了我读过的一些话，比如，永远不要相信没有丑闻或者主角看起来不错的回忆录或传记。
Yeah, like any biography where it's just that's hagiography, right?
是的，就像任何传记一样，只是传记，对吧？
Is that like how they describe like the lives of saints like no one's that interested in reading?
这就像他们描述的圣人的生活一样，没有人对阅读感兴趣吗？
How it all went great like we want to hear struggle.
一切进展顺利，就像我们想听到斗争一样。
We want to and you trust a narrator When they actually Jason's really great at telling stories where he's kind of the butt of the joke Like he loves it when he has been humiliated like he loves telling those stories.
我们希望你相信一个叙述者，当他们实际上杰森非常擅长讲故事时，他是一个笑话的笑柄，就像他喜欢被羞辱一样，就像他喜欢讲这些故事一样。
I always admired that about him He's really good at telling stories where he doesn't look that great in the story, but him telling it is charming and you forgive him whatever his behavior was because he's willing to share it.
我一直很欣赏他这一点，他真的很擅长讲故事，虽然他在故事中看起来不太好，但他讲故事很迷人，无论他的行为是什么，你都会原谅他，因为他愿意分享。
It's almost like one of the things, this is going deep in the weeds, but one of the reasons that the Torah, the Old Testament, was a revolutionary kind of earthquake and narrative is because Every story of a people was written by the victors, and it was written about how great everyone was.
这几乎就像其中一件事，这正在深入杂草中，但是《托拉》，《旧约》，是一场革命性的地震和叙事的原因之一是因为一个民族的每一个故事都是由胜利者写的，并且写的是每个人有多么伟大。
And the Torah and the story of this little tribe that got knocked around is just one idiotic move after another.
《托拉》和这个被击倒的小部落的故事只是一个接一个的愚蠢举动。
Like they really cataloged their own folly, right?
就像他们真的记录了自己的愚蠢行为一样，对吗？
And their own, and how they didn't listen to the law or this way, and they didn't, you know, And it's maybe it's endured because it's honest.
还有他们自己的，以及他们如何不听法律或以这种方式，他们没有，你知道，也许它之所以能忍受，是因为它是诚实的。
And it's not, hey, geography.
嘿，这不是地理。
It's, I think we trust people.
我认为我们信任人们。
You, when I hear, when you list your accomplishments, you breed competition.
当我听说你列出你的成就时，你就滋生了竞争。
When you lead with vulnerability, you breed community, you know?
当你带着脆弱来领导时，你就孕育了社区，你知道吗？
Yes.
是的。
So I think, you know, even though Ted, sometimes you can go like, oh God, why won't this guy get it together?
所以我想，你知道，即使特德，有时你也会想，天哪，为什么这个人不团结起来？
It's actually his superpower.
这其实就是他的超能力。
that he is leading with, here's another way I messed up.
他所领导的，这是我搞砸的另一种方式。
Oh my God, let me tell you about this night.
天哪，让我告诉你今晚的事吧。
I really put my foot in my mouth.
我真是把脚放在嘴里了。
Let me tell you this.
让我告诉你这一点。
Future dad is the embodiment of this.
未来的爸爸就是这一点的体现。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
Like it's all getting dinged up.
好像一切都被搞砸了。
And in some ways, that's actually, it's occurring to me now, it's an incredibly loving thing to tell your children when they're ready to hear.
从某些方面来说，这实际上是我现在所经历的，当你的孩子准备好听的时候告诉他们是一件非常有爱的事情。
I'm an imperfect human being, your dad just grew up.
我是一个不完美的人，你爸爸才刚刚长大。
But also, he landed on his feet and he did okay.
而且，他双脚着地，表现还不错。
So I think it's a great observation that there's a kind of microcosm, macrocosm thing going on here that Jordana pointed out.
所以我认为这是一个很好的观察，乔丹娜指出这里正在发生一种微观、宏观的事情。
Yeah, it's a great observation.
是的，这是一个很棒的观察。
It's my wife's smart.
我妻子很聪明。
Your wife's really smart.
你老婆真聪明。
She's really good.
她真的很好。
You should hold on to that one.
你应该抓住那个。
Whether or not she's officially a relationship expert, I think you should keep her around.
无论她是否正式成为关系专家，我认为你都应该把她留在身边。
I think she's maybe a really, I think she's really weird.
我认为她可能真的，我认为她真的很奇怪。
Whether or not she's officially your wife.
无论她是否正式成为你的妻子。
And I was like, yeah, she's officially my wife.
我当时想，是的，她正式是我的妻子了。
Back off, man.
退后吧，伙计。
Well, that was super fun, Craig, going deep on that episode.
嗯，那真是太有趣了，克雷格，深入探讨那一集。
I really enjoyed that.
我真的很喜欢这样。
I like that one.
我喜欢那个。
Yeah, it's a good one.
是的，这是一件好事。
Isn't it funny that we're gonna have favorite episodes of this show that won't necessarily correspond to our favorite episodes of How I Met Your Mother?
我们最喜欢的剧集不一定与我们最喜欢的《老爸老妈浪漫史》的剧集相对应，这不是很有趣吗？
They're just like, the conversation, it led somewhere cool, right?
他们就像，谈话，它带来了一些很酷的地方，对吧？
Like it'll be.
就像它会那样。
Himium episode was garbage, but this podcast episode was really fun.
Himium 剧集很垃圾，但是这个播客剧集真的很有趣。
The circuits were jammed though.
但电路被堵塞了。
The circuits were jammed.
电路被堵塞了。
If we can't get anything going, like we're just like the circuits are jammed.
如果我们无法进行任何操作，就像电路被堵塞一样。
The circuits are just jammed today.
今天电路刚刚堵塞。
Look, that's New Year's Eve for ya.
瞧，这就是你的除夕夜。
You're welcome, but for that turn of phrase.
不客气，但换个说法。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, we like to end our episode with some viewer listener male and we have a lovely letter today from Jessica and Craig is going to read it for us.
好吧，我们想用一些男性观众听众来结束我们的这一集，今天我们收到了杰西卡写的一封可爱的信，克雷格将为我们读这封信。
Yes, this is lovely and a little conversation talking point emerges at the end of it.
是的，这很可爱，最后出现了一些谈话要点。
So here we go, ready?
那么我们开始吧，准备好了吗？
This is Jessica from Jessica.
这是杰西卡的杰西卡。
She says, Hi, Josh and Craig.
她说，嗨，乔什和克雷格。
Jessica here from New Brunswick, Canada, shout out to Canada.
来自加拿大新不伦瑞克省的杰西卡向加拿大大声喊叫。
We love our Canadian fans and we love our Canadian characters as a plural?
我们爱我们的加拿大粉丝，我们爱我们的加拿大角色作为复数？
I think we had a few over the years.
我想这些年来我们有过一些。
My husband Tristan introduced me to him when we first started dating and it quickly became a cherished part of our lives.
当我们第一次开始约会时，我的丈夫特里斯坦向他介绍了我，这很快就成为我们生活中珍贵的一部分。
The show holds such significance to us that it actually played a role in our wedding day.
这个节目对我们来说意义重大，它实际上在我们的婚礼上发挥了作用。
From gifting my soon-to-be husband a blue French horn to open the morning of the wedding to having Heaven by the Walkman play during our recessional Great Song.
从送给我即将成为丈夫的蓝色圆号作为婚礼早上的开场白，到在我们经济衰退的伟大歌曲中播放随身听播放的《天堂》。
You have to wait till the end of the series, you get to it.
你必须等到这个系列结束，你才能看到它。
and the unforgettable moment of our bosses surprising us with a cameo of Josh during our heartfelt speech.
在我们衷心的演讲中，我们的老板让乔什客串，这一令人难忘的时刻让我们感到惊讶。
I know cameos might seem like a small gesture to celebrities, but hearing Josh say, as Ted Mosby said, love is the best thing we do on our wedding day, was nothing short of legendary, captured beautifully in the photos and video footage of our reactions.
我知道客串对名人来说似乎是一个小举动，但听到乔什说，正如特德·莫斯比所说，爱是我们在婚礼当天做的最好的事情，这简直就是传奇，在我们反应的照片和视频片段中完美地捕捉到了。
Please send us those, by the way, Jessica.
顺便说一句，杰西卡，请把那些寄给我们。
It warms my heart to see how both of you remain humbled and perhaps a touch astonished by the profound impact your creation has had on countless lives.
看到你们俩保持谦逊，或许还对你们的创作对无数生命产生的深远影响感到惊讶，这让我感到温暖。
My question for both of you is this.
我想问你们俩的问题是这样的。
Is there a show or film series that evokes the same feelings in you that Himyum does for its fans?
有没有一部电视剧或电影系列能够像 Himyum 为其粉丝带来同样的感受？
I eagerly anticipate this journey of dissecting every last episode.
我热切地期待着这段剖析最后一集的旅程。
Please know that you both and Carter have conjured something truly spectacular, a treasure that will continue to resonate for years to come.
请知道，你们和卡特已经创造了一些真正壮观的东西，一件将在未来几年继续引起共鸣的宝藏。
Thank you, Jessica.
谢谢你，杰西卡。
Well, thanks Jessica.
嗯，谢谢杰西卡。
What a lovely, every part of that, being part of their wedding.
成为他们婚礼的一部分，这一切真是太可爱了。
I love that you did that cameo.
我喜欢你客串。
Did you, I don't know if you remember doing that specific one years ago or not.
我不知道你是否还记得一年前做过这样的事。
And did you know what was going to be part of a wedding?
您知道婚礼会包含哪些内容吗？
I don't, I'm, I mean, I get asked to do weddings.
我不，我，我是说，我被邀请参加婚礼。
I always make a joke about being underdressed.
我总是开玩笑说自己衣着朴素。
That's kind of my, um, but yeah, I mean, I, sometimes they'll say, can you throw in a Ted Mosby quote, you love.
这是我的，嗯，但是，是的，我的意思是，我，有时他们会说，你能引用泰德·莫斯比的名言吗，你喜欢。
And for me, that's like the one, you know, from, uh, for a wedding.
对我来说，这就像，你知道，来自，呃，一场婚礼。
I think that's the, the best one.
我认为这是最好的一个。
Yeah.
是的。
It's the whole series, right?
这是整个系列吧？
that if you had to distill the series down to one line, that could be in the running to be the one.
如果你必须将这个系列提炼成一行，那可能就是那一行。
And I think there's different kinds of love, like we have that one word, but like C.S.
我认为爱有不同的类型，就像我们有这个词一样，但就像 C.S.
Lewis has a book called The Four Loves, right?
刘易斯有一本书叫《四种爱》，对吗？
It's like Eros and Philos and, like there's different, but I think love more broadly speaking is kind of how it may or not, because there's certainly friendship, love.
就像爱神和斐洛斯一样，有不同之处，但我认为更广泛地说，爱是一种可能或不可能的爱，因为肯定有友谊、爱。
It's so much about friendship.
这非常关乎友谊。
It's mostly that, right?
大部分都是这样，对吧？
In the end, it's a lot of dates, but the friendships there the whole time.
最后，虽然有很多次约会，但友谊始终存在。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you have pieces of art that live and take residence in your heart the way that Hemium has for these fans?
您是否有像 Hemium 为这些粉丝提供的那样，在您心中存在并驻扎的艺术品？
I mean, for me, I feel like what Jessica's talking about, and I think the feeling she's talking about can only be achieved through a franchise, a series, something that goes on a while that you can spend that much time with.
我的意思是，对我来说，我感觉就像杰西卡所说的那样，而且我认为她所说的感觉只能通过特许经营、系列、持续一段时间、你可以花很多时间的东西来实现。
Your favorite movie that's like an hour and a half long, two hours long, you can go back into that world over and over, but it's kind of always that one thing.
你最喜欢的电影大约一个半小时，两个小时长，你可以一遍又一遍地回到那个世界，但它总是那么一件事。
It's hard to replicate that what she's talking about, what a TV series can give you.
很难复制她所说的以及电视剧可以给你的东西。
It's such a gift to get nine seasons to do a show.
能连续演出九季真是一份礼物。
So for me, what comes up for me when she says that is like Star Wars.
所以对我来说，当她说这就像星球大战时，我会想到什么。
The Star Wars franchise just getting to that stretching across my entire childhood into my adult life.
《星球大战》系列刚刚开始贯穿我的整个童年直到我的成年生活。
The Harry Potter books and movies give me some of that feeling.
哈利波特书籍和电影给了我一些这种感觉。
And then sitcom wise, you know, what made me want of right sitcoms was was Cheers mostly the show Cheers Buffy gave me some of that in my 20s and led into the show and casting Alice and had again and it's funny I had one other thing that came up for me from her question was I just watched the Conan O'Brien Mark Twain prize show on Netflix which is great.
然后情景喜剧方面，你知道，让我想要合适的情景喜剧的是《干杯》，主要是《干杯》巴菲在我20多岁的时候给了我一些这样的节目，并带我进入了这部剧，并选了爱丽丝，然后又做了一次，有趣的是，我从她的问题中想到了另一件事，那就是我刚刚在Netflix上观看了柯南·奥布莱恩·马克·吐温奖颁奖典礼，这很棒。
Is that where everybody brings their A-game in that Feral so funny I saw that clip.
那是每个人在《野性》中表现出色的地方吗？太有趣了，我看到了那个剪辑。
Will Feral so funny watch it watch the whole thing it's It's all killer, no filler.
威尔·费拉尔（Will Feral）如此有趣地观看它观看整个事情，这都是杀手，没有填充物。
It's like everybody comes and brings their A-game because they love Conan so much.
就好像每个人都带来了他们的顶级游戏，因为他们非常喜欢柯南。
And why am I bringing that up?
我为什么要提出这个？
It's because watching that made me realize how much Conan O'Brien has meant to me from 1993 premiering at Dave Letterman's old slot.
因为观看这部影片让我意识到，自 1993 年在戴夫·莱特曼的老片子首映以来，柯南·奥布莱恩对我来说意义重大。
Dave Letterman, a lot to me too.
戴夫·莱特曼，对我来说也有很​​多。
I wrote for Dave Letterman a few years after that.
几年后我为戴夫·莱特曼写作。
I wanted to write for Conan.
我想为柯南写作。
Carter and I both really were angling to write for Conan.
卡特和我都非常想为柯南写作。
And we got, they were not hiring, but Letterman was incredibly lucky.
我们知道，他们没有招聘，但莱特曼非常幸运。
and I love Letterman equally as much in a different way.
我以不同的方式同样爱莱特曼。
But Conan, just watching the Netflix special about his sort of totality of his career, I felt like emotional watching it because I'm like this, I just feel like I've lived 30 years with this guy.
但是柯南，只是在观看 Netflix 特别讲述他职业生涯的整体时，我就很激动地观看它，因为我就是这样，我只是觉得我和这个家伙一起生活了 30 年。
And I got this brief little intersection with him where he came and spoilers.
我和他有过短暂的交集，他来了，剧透了。
It was a background extra and an episode of How Much A Mother.
这是《How much A Mother》的背景花絮和一集。
We will explain that more when we get to it many years from now.
多年后我们会进一步解释这一点。
And after that, he knew that Carter and I were big fans and he asked us to, we asked him to lunch.
在那之后，他知道卡特和我是他的忠实粉丝，他邀请我们，我们请他共进午餐。
And so a few weeks later, we got to spend a couple hours having lunch with Conan, and it was just, I just had this feeling in watching it, I think is what Jessica's talking about, which is you just can't, not many things can give you the feeling that you spent your whole life with somebody.
几周后，我们花了几个小时和柯南一起吃午饭，我在看它的时候就有了这种感觉，我想这就是杰西卡所说的，这是你做不到的，没有多少事情能让你感觉你和某人度过了一生。
You've spent years and years and years in this world or with this energy, and so I'm so happy that Hemium was that to her.
你已经在这个世界上或带着这种能量度过了很多年，所以我很高兴 Hemium 对她来说就是这样。
What is it for you, Josh?
乔什，这对你来说是什么？
What comes up to you for you of that?
你对此有何感想？
Like, what have I held with me this over cross, across such a long time?
比如说，这么长的时间里，我到底带了什么东西？
Yeah, well, we've talked about the movie Sing Street, which is one of my favorite movies.
是的，我们已经讨论过电影《歌唱街》，这是我最喜欢的电影之一。
I've just seen so much of it.
我刚刚看到了这么多。
I love that movie.
我喜欢那部电影。
I just re-watched that movie.
我刚刚又看了一遍那部电影。
I bet Elliott likes that movie too.
我打赌埃利奥特也喜欢那部电影。
Has he seen it?
他看到了吗？
Ah, he hasn't seen that.
啊，他没见过。
Yeah, that would be a great one to watch.
是的，那将是一场精彩的观看。
I think he.
我认为他。
What a music movie.
多么棒的音乐电影啊。
One of the great music movies.
伟大的音乐电影之一。
And great brother movies.
还有很棒的兄弟电影。
Yeah, it just works on all levels for me.
是的，它对我来说在各个层面都有效。
Hell, I'll let you know.
地狱，我会让你知道的。
I'm a huge fan of the before trilogy, the link letter.
我是前三部曲的超级粉丝，链接信。
See, that's a trilogy.
你看，这就是三部曲。
Because you have years and years that spans 15 years, those three movies.
因为那三部电影已经过去了 15 年。
and you get to watch them age, which is always so moving to watch people get older.
你可以看着他们变老，看着人们变老总是那么令人感动。
And I just think there's something, he really catches something in those movies.
我只是觉得有些东西，他在那些电影中确实抓住了一些东西。
The last one's almost like impossible to watch in some ways, because it's so tragic, but also so beautiful.
最后一个在某些方面几乎是不可能观看的，因为它是如此悲惨，但也如此美丽。
But I love those, I'm trying to think, I mean, there's certain authors that I, just I'm always coming back to, I've talked about this before, but Nick Cave does this weekly, it's called The Red Hand Files, And he just answers kind of like, reader, male, and he's, he's the most beautiful writer.
但我喜欢那些，我试图思考，我的意思是，有一些作家，我总是会回来，我以前谈过这个，但是尼克·凯夫每周都会这样做，它被称为“红手档案”，他只是回答有点像，读者，男性，他是，他是最美丽的作家。
He's really funny.
他真的很有趣。
And it's reliably the best thing I read every week.
这确实是我每周读到的最好的东西。
And I feel like I get to sit around this campfire with Nick Cave and have him tell.
我觉得我可以和尼克·凯夫一起坐在篝火旁，让他讲述。
He wrote one today that was so funny about him and Nick Cage getting confused.
他今天写了一篇关于他和尼克·凯奇混淆的非常有趣的文章。
And he was drinking with this guy whose wife was leaving him.
他和这个妻子正在离开他的人一起喝酒。
And he was like, my wife loves you, man.
他说，我的妻子爱你，伙计。
I need to tell her.
我需要告诉她。
realized he thought he was Nick Cage, the actor, not Nick Cage, the rock star.
意识到他以为自己是演员尼克·凯奇，而不是摇滚明星尼克·凯奇。
So he ends up writing an autograph for her, and he ends up talking about raising Arizona was a tough shoot, but the Cone Brothers is so great, and he was so drunk, just imitating Nick Cage.
所以他最终为她写了一张亲笔签名，最后他谈到抚养亚利桑那州是一个艰难的拍摄，但锥体兄弟是如此伟大，而他喝醉了，只是模仿尼克·凯奇。
But I love those so much, and I think the campfires I tend to gravitate around are a little more probably movies or books, but you know, I grew up watching Cheers and Family Ties and that, you know, that Thursday lineup, that night court LA law, I mean, so I feel, I watched so much more TV when I was a kid than I do now, much to my wife, Sugarin.
但我非常喜欢这些，我认为我倾向于围绕的篝火更可能是电影或书籍，但你知道，我是看着《干杯》和《家庭纽带》长大的，你知道，周四的阵容，那天晚上洛杉矶法庭的法律，我的意思是，所以我觉得，我小时候看的电视比现在多得多，对我的妻子苏格林来说非常多。
But yeah, I mean, I don't think anyone gets in this business that we're in without having things that have really taken up residence in their psyche, you know?
但是，是的，我的意思是，我认为任何人在进入我们所从事的这个行业时，都没有真正在他们的心灵中占有一席之地，你知道吗？
And I'm sure we'll end this, and I'll think of eight more in one of those.
我确信我们会结束这个，并且我会在其中一个中考虑另外八个。
Well, I think you hit the nail on the head by saying the word campfire.
嗯，我认为你说的“篝火”这个词击中了要害。
I think Jessica feels like she was around this campfire with us for all these years.
我想杰西卡感觉这些年来她一直和我们一起围坐在篝火旁。
We're all telling stories.
我们都在讲故事。
And I think it's such a gift to have that campfire kind of burn for as many, for enough years to sort of tell enough stories around.
我认为让篝火燃烧尽可能多的时间，足够长的时间来讲述足够多的故事，真是一份礼物。
And I think it's so rare to get to do that.
我认为能够做到这一点是非常罕见的。
That's why my brain went to like things I've spent lots of time with.
这就是为什么我的大脑开始喜欢我花了很多时间做的事情。
I think that's what she's talking about.
我想这就是她所说的。
So yeah, thank you Jessica for the question.
是的，谢谢杰西卡提出的问题。
Thank you for spending that much time with us around the campfire.
感谢您与我们一起在篝火旁度过了这么多时间。
And this new campfire too.
还有这个新的篝火。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
I am guilty, please equip me.
我有罪，请装备我。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
在纽约市，所有的罪孽都被宽恕。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 和克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 主持并监制，并由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又名 Z 世代大师，是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
That really does help the show.
这确实对节目有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
无论哪里有售，都可以订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作《事情不是这样发生的》，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上查看他出版的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的 Dead Fathers Society。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign, to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息，这显示了正在进行的为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。